i mean you're asking the right questions
for anybody that really knows their math
and science
and it must be hard knows about you
you're asking exactly the right
questions
some of the the deepest questions i've
gotten so i really appreciate it
how's it going man great how about you
it's going well how's the weather it's
been like an irvine oh it's well
it's it's probably the best weather you
could have in the world i mean it's
almost like we have a thermostatist
that's
it's just gorgeous here year round so i
have no complaints
it's warm with all the
quarantine and lockdowns are you okay is
it all right in your mental health
do you prefer it i'm okay i it's um
for me it's great in the sense that i'm
i'm enjoying um
less distraction and i'm able to focus
on studying some mathematics and physics
that i'm interested in studying so
it's it's good it's of course very very
sad to see the millions infected and
hundreds of thousands 140 000 at this
point that are
dead so yeah that's that's that's
horrific and
you know the threat of the pandemic
expanding and so forth is you know not
much fun
um so and i got family and relatives and
so forth that i'm concerned about so
yeah
yeah i'm similar in that i'm ambivalent
about it i like it because
it removes any distractions and i too am
studying math and physics on the side
and
and this whole situation has been
salutary for me
but it's obviously not for everyone has
it changed your views at all
has covered giving you given you any
insight or any different ideas with
regards to your theories which we'll get
into
uh it just confirms what we learned from
evolutionary psychology about that
about human nature and in groups and out
groups and
um the one the reasons we evolved logic
and reason it wasn't in pursuit of truth
but to
to support ideas that we already believe
so so we just see this being played out
in
in the big debates about masks and so
forth that are
that are going on and and you know the
yeah we see human nature being played
out in a big way and we and we see the
results in terms of
uh you know a big failure in our country
right now the the
rates of infection are going up the
deaths are we're number one in the world
in terms of the number of deaths and
infections and so forth
maybe not per capita but um but but
still
for the world's richest country with
the the wonderful scientific
establishment that we have you would
think that there would be
just no problem in us getting together
organizing and defeating this thing
but but there there's the whole aspect
of human evolutionary psychology
and um that that's playing playing
itself out uh
large and so so and i study evolutionary
psychology and what's going on
does does make sense it's tragic for us
as a as a population but it makes sense
in terms of human nature
do you meditate yes daily
what kind of meditation mindfulness or
transcendental or
um it's
silence nothing else
pure silence no poses i do whatever
feels comfortable but it's i spend
probably at least three hours a day
in pure silence that's it not looking at
a screen or reading
nothing not walking not walking
just silence sitting lying the pose
doesn't matter to me
but it's just pure silence and um
being just being aware of whatever i
feel
in the moment in being aware of thoughts
as they come up and just
if they come up then i'll let them go
and go back to silence
it's very very simple what's what i find
tricky about meditation this is why i
don't do it
is that as soon as i start to not that
the thoughts intrude but
that great productive thoughts come up
and then i have to write them down
because i find that when i don't it's
rare that i get them again
so do you sit with a pen and paper if
you have a particularly brilliant
thought do you just allow that to
escape i let it go it's over the years
it's only maybe one or two times that
i've actually written something down
it's i i just don't i just let it come
and i let it go
i have a fairly good memory for the
stuff that comes up if i want to later
so so
maybe maybe if i was really concerned
that i would forget something that i
really wanted i might be doing that but
i'm not too concerned about it i can
remember stuff later
but i just you know it's it's a matter
what i find it's the meditation process
for me
is what i can imagine it's like for a
caterpillar to go through metamorphosis
it turns out when the caterpillar is
inside the chrysalis the immune cells
of the caterpillar attack
and try to kill that in fact they do
kill the cells
that are responsible for the
transformation into a butterfly
they attack and kill attack and kill
until they're overwhelmed
and and then all most of the structure
of the caterpillar liquefies
and then it's reformed into the
butterfly from the point of view of the
caterpillar
that that can't be fun and the immune
system indicates
that it's it's not welcomed by the
caterpillar at all it's it's fought
to the death by the immune system until
the immune system's overwhelmed
but from the point of view of the
butterfly it's it's
a brand new creation so it depends on
whether you take the
the point of view of the caterpillar or
the butterfly most of the time i've been
the caterpillar
um but i'm starting a little bit to
welcome the destruction of everything i
know
the destruction of deeply held beliefs
the destruction of
my fears and so forth defense mechanisms
letting all that stuff slowly be
destroyed
just in pure silence and then watching
whatever new might might come up i mean
it's hard
to imagine that the caterpillar has any
idea what it's going to be turned into
it's just fighting it to the death until
he can't fight anymore
and then it liquefies so from the
caterpillar's point of view it's just
all loss and death and destruction
but there's a rebirth and that's the way
i feel about
meditation that it's i'm allowing a
transformation
to occur of which i'm arbitrarily
ignorant about
its true nature and i can only tell you
after i've taken the next step what it
was like
so are you aware of any studies that
have been done
as to the memory of a caterpillar when
it becomes into its butterfly phase that
it has and that it retains
certain memories that's right i i have
i mean i'm not an expert on it but i do
recall um stories about that that if you
give some kind of
like aversive training to the
caterpillar it might be there
um the reactions might be there on the
butterfly that kind of thing
i was watching a neuroscientist say that
some memories might be non-vocal or not
localized into the neuronal formation in
the brain
and the reason why he thinks so is
controversial and it's extremely
rudimentary in his research right now is
because of the arctic squirrel
the arctic squirrel when it goes into
hibernation and i believe most creatures
experience this their brain degenerates
to such a degree that
it's it's not clear that memory should
certain memories
should survive yet they do with the
arctic squirrel it's interesting
do you eat a certain kind of breakfast
or follow a diet
uh i i try to um have a
low acid diet so i have lots of oatmeal
i have oatmeal you know for breakfast
and
try to do low acid low fat so i'll have
um an omelet with mostly egg whites
maybe one egg yolk
um and some fresh fruit
my wife is a vegetarian i'm not but um
so she
is she makes up vegetables all the time
so eat her vegetables and then i'll cook
some fish
um chicken i don't do beef that often
but i
don't avoid it either but i tend to
focus on fish and chicken
but you know i'll have a little bit of
red meat so i try to eat
i eat three times a day i don't snack at
all
and i after dinner i don't eat any
snacks so i
don't eat usually from 6 30 in the
evening
until at least 7 30 the next day i i
never eat
a bite and that's just been my habit for
for decades
i don't need it all for like 12 hours 13
hours
see i intermittent fast but i do so
because i'm filled with
with avarice and i i just want to eat
whatever i see so i
fast for like when i spoke to eric
weinstein i think at that point during
the interview i had not eaten for 65
hours or so not plenty but but i do that
before i conduct my
podcasts or interviews generally do you
have any
rituals that or habits that you do
before you
speak or before you study besides
meditation
no i i i'm pretty comfortable talking i
i you know
i was a professor at the university of
california for 37 years and had to give
lectures all the time
to big audiences and so for me it
talking is is is not an issue at all so
i mean i was working out just until a
couple minutes before we got on
onto this podcast i had had an hour
window so i i
i got a little um you know bench and you
know dumbbells that
that i use and i i weight train three
times a week and do aerobics
three or four times the other three or
four days of the week so i try to have a
regular thing so i was doing that just
before the podcast
so so yeah no i i don't
you usually have to i mean i i usually
just
go and and talk and enjoy it
i was looking at your background and it
said you studied initially computational
psychology
what is computational psychology yeah so
it was
computational psychology was the name of
my my phd
at mit and there i was in the artificial
intelligence laboratory
at mit and in what's now the brain and
cognitive sciences department
and so what i was doing was a
combination of studying
just artificial intelligence and at the
time it was you know good old-fashioned
artificial intelligence it wasn't the
neural network stuff
at that point because that was from 1979
to 1983 neural networks came
into their own a little bit a few years
later um
so i was doing more of the good
old-fashioned ai stuff but still it was
you know i was studying human vision and
computer vision and the idea was
you had a good theory if you could build
a computer that could work
so if you have a theory about how we see
in 3d build it if you have
you know if you can't build it then i'm
not sure you have a theory so it was
that really hard-nosed attitude so
and then on the other side i was looking
with in the brain and cognitive science
department
um at human vision and the
neurophysiology of human vision
psychophysical experiments about how we
see in 3d
object recognition colors and so forth
so the idea was to
reverse engineer biological vision
systems
which are the only ones that worked at
the time and take the insights and try
to build
computer vision systems that implemented
what we learned
and that way we would know we weren't
just you know fooling ourselves into
thinking we understood
if it doesn't work then you don't
understand go back and
scratch your head a little bit and
figure out what's really going on so it
was sorry
around what year was this i was there um
from 1979 until 1983 at mit
and i was very fortunate to have two
wonderful advisors david maher and
whitman richards
um so both of them had their foot
in the ai lab and in the brain and
cognitive science department
cool cool you know i i see a few
different strands to your theories and
this
just for the people listening or
watching this is going to be
extremely technical or much more so than
most of the other interviews that you
have online and
which i think stay on at a cursory level
particularly
particularly because you're conversing
with people who don't have a
mathematical background or a physics
background so as far as i can delineate
you have the consciousness the conscious
agent model
interface theory of perception that's
number two bayesian decision theory
which i believe you
mended to computational
evolutionary perception i could be wrong
about that and then
number four you have some new papers on
eigenforms which i haven't studied much
because i don't know much about
modular forms and heck algebras so i
didn't get a chance to read them
but uh but are those is that a fair
summary of your work or
are there more yeah so evolutionary game
theory i i work on
um yeah um bayesian models of perception
markovian models of the dynamics of
consciousness yeah
out of curiosity this this is getting
somewhat out of left field
why did you choose g to represent the
the braille space for
decisions because when i was for those
listening
there's this it's there's a relatively
simple structure though
non-trivial called sigma algebras and
then there's markup kernels and then you
have w
you have which is the world state then
you have x which x experience i
imagine you chose x because of
experience world w okay great but g
what does that have to do with decisions
why did you choose that to just run out
of letters or
yeah we're running out of letters and we
already had a for the kernel fractions i
mean
in some sense g is the set of actions
that you're going to take we already
used action
a for the action kernel so i used g for
the group of of actions that you could
take
i was thinking about at the time that it
might be have a group structure as well
as a measurable structure
so use that's why i use g because
already take taken a for the kernel
itself
but the easiest way to think about the
definition of a conscious agent
is that it's just three kernels there's
a perception kernel
you so you get the world that influences
you through a perception kernel
in other words whatever the state of the
world is it probabilistically affects
what your experiences are that's what a
kernel p does
so whatever the state of the world is
you get a probabilistic effect on your
experiences
then the d kernel is whatever my
experiences are they probabilistically
affect the actions that i choose
and then my action kernel is whatever
actions i choose they probabilistically
affect the state of the world
very very simple triangle the state of
the world affects my experiences
my experiences affect the choices i make
the choices i make
affect the state of the world right okay
now please forgive me if i jump around i
have 90 questions here
and what you're saying right now
brings me to question number 80 let's
say so it's gonna go all over the place
why did you have x when you could just
go from w to g directly by composing d
after
p so that is to say for the people you
can explain what i'm saying to the
people so in case
right so
the the idea when i was working on this
model of the perception decision in
action the idea
is first i'm trying to
model the process of observation
so you know i studied computational
vision at mit and now and then
uc irvine and it turns out when you look
at all the specific mathematical models
that we have
they all have a similar structure i was
trying to capture that similar structure
a sort of a bayesian inference kind of
structure but i wanted to actually
capture
the fact that we we do have these
conscious experiences like i'm
perceiving a three-dimensional
object like an apple and i'm seeing its
three-dimensional shape as colors
it's textures and so forth so i needed a
space x
of experiences to capture what what it
was that i was perceiving
but then you know perception doesn't
occur in a void
there's a perspective perception action
loop right there's this a point that
sort of an activist um approaches uh
highlighting that is that
perception and action sort of work
together and so i i want a model in
which
i have experiences but those are tied to
my actions and those actions
affect the world and my experiences in
in a loop
and so that's why there's this this loop
structure to it and to leave
out the experiences would actually be to
leave out um
the whole point which is to understand
my perceptions
okay when i watch your interviews with
people who most of the time aren't
physicists they seem to be resistant
on that space time is emergent like
michael schermer
and he was saying well you probably
talked to the minority of physicists
that think that
space time is emerging that's not in
fact true
most physicists as far as i know
actually believe that space time is
emergent
nema is one of them lee smolin
so why do you think that there's this
aversion
to modest that is monoism
theory is predicated on the primacy of
consciousness rather than the primacy
being material
why is it that that's the sticking point
right well and even among physicists
who recognize that space time isn't
fundamental
um you won't find very many of them
arguing that therefore consciousness is
a good candidate for what is fundamental
um i've been to an fqxi
um meeting of physicists where they were
looking at the role of the observer in
physics
at banff a few years ago and
even in that context where where they
were looking at the role of the observer
in physics i didn't see any of the
physicists there interested in taking
consciousness
as fundamental and and i think
the attitude is why take such a huge
leap
i mean letting go of space time is one
thing but jumping into consciousness
i mean that that for i think most
physicists would say that's a much
bigger leap than we need to take let's
try to find just some deeper structure
beyond space
time and for example this is i think the
brilliant work that nema or kanye hamed
is doing where he's saying
look we can look
at these so-called positive geometries
behind space-time the amplitude
a sociohedron and other things that he's
finding
positive grasmanians the bigger
structure that
includes many of these and and
he doesn't know what that realm is about
which is fine but he's finding the
mathematical structure so he's finding
that there are these symmetries like in
the amplitude
um that can't be captured
in space-time they also have found that
the mathematical
description of the scattering amplitudes
the computations of the scattering
amplitudes
become much much simpler when you let go
of space time if you use
um feynman diagrams and have virtual
particles in space time then you could
have hundreds or thousands of pages
but in this deeper space that he's
finding this pure math
um it collapses to a few terms that you
can compute by hand
and so so i think that the physicists
are saying let's you know let's not
jump further than we have to let's if we
have to let go of spacetime let's just
find
some let's let's let the mathematics
guide us first
um and we can try things like well let's
just try like quantum bits in quantum
case
seth lloyd i think at mit took a a an
approach
and quantum what quantum bits and
quantum gates
gates right okay right so your space
time isn't fundamental let's
let's pause it something that's not
conscious just quantum bits and quantum
gates
and what what seth lloyd was able to
show is that you could
in some sense get little patches of
space time
um general relativistic space time where
the curvature of this little patch was
proportional to the
action of the gate and so instead of
starting with space time is fundamental
you start with quantum bits and quantum
gates um where those bits and gates come
from again
that's now that's that's your new
assumption it's not space time it's just
bits and gates and you can ask
you know who ordered that why should the
universe be fundamentally that
now so the reason why i go there
even though i think most physicists
don't is that
as a cognitive neuroscientist i'm very
interested
in the problem what's called the heart
problem of consciousness
right we have lots of correlations
between brain activity
and conscious experiences like i i like
to use the example of area v4
of cortex left hemispheres back over
here somewhere
if you take a magnet and just touch it
to your skull there a transcranial
magnetic stimulator and inhibit before
you will lose all color experiences in
the right visual field everything to the
right of where you're looking
you will lose color experiences you turn
off the magnet color experiences come
back
and we have dozens maybe hundreds of
correlations like that between specific
kinds of neural activity
and specific conscious experiences but
we have no scientific theories
that can explain um that correlation
there are none
um for any specific there's not a
scientific theory that can explain even
one specific
conscious experience like the taste of
chocolate or the smell of garlic that
says for example
this pattern of brain activity or this
functional aspect of brain activity
um must be the taste of chocolate it
couldn't be the the smell of
um you know a rose and these are the
precise reasons why
there's just nothing on the table and so
i'm trying to
solve two problems i'm trying to say the
reason why space time is
not fundamental is because something
else is consciousness
and if i start with consciousness i can
perhaps get a theory that explains
this correlation between conscious
experiences and brain states but i don't
start with
something in space time namely brain
states i don't start with brain states
and and figure out how they cause
consciousness i go the other way around
to start with consciousness and show how
it
creates space time as a data structure
and
brains and neurons as particular objects
within that data structure
so so the idea of the big picture idea
is
if space time isn't fundamental as the
physicists are now recognizing
then objects in space time
and just so people are clear this is not
as this is not new that space time isn't
fundamental it's not like a kooky theory
this has been going around since the 80s
just so that they don't think you're
glumming onto some fat
that that that's right and yeah you know
i think mo as you said most physicists
now most you know first ranked
theoretical physicist just recognize
that it's sort of just
of course space time isn't fundamental
and of course our job is to try to
figure out what's the next step
um and it's not such a crazy idea either
right when you're speaking with michael
schumer he was just blown away there's
no way that space time can't be
fundamental
there's a cup in front of me i see the
cup that's that's beside the point
there's been many times where we have an
effective theory and then we find one
that's more fundamental that produces
that
there's no reason to think that our
current theories aren't effective
right and and my colleagues in the
cognitive neurosciences can can be
forgiven
if they don't understand the state of
the play in in physics right i mean
they're they
were taught some physics
in their backgrounds and they have just
absorbed
the idea that space-time is fundamental
and that's perfectly fine in a newtonian
universe and
even in special relativity um it's and
in general relativity is when you put
einstein's theory of gravity together
with quantum theory
that you get the problem and that that's
sort of beyond
what you could expect a normal cognitive
neuroscientist to to really have studied
and so
so you know i don't i don't blame my
colleagues there
for for not understanding this um but
but for for any real professional
physicist
is just obviously you generally quantum
field they don't play well
i see there's two problems one if you
encounter the general public and when i
say general public i mean
the rationally minded skeptics like
michael sherman or maybe even sam harris
and they'll their sticking point might
be the space-time fundamental aspect
right but then when you speak to a
physicist their sticking point would be
consciousness you're saying
consciousness is fun like i agree with
you space time is emerging but then
consciousness is complicated that's an
emerging phenomenon
for a neuroscientist to figure out or or
some people like penrose there's some
quantum mechanical aspect to it but it's
still
somewhat complicated it's not simple why
would you start with consciousness
right okay i have a question about sure
can you just respond to
why that is the idea
is very very simple if space time isn't
fundamental
then objects in spacetime aren't
fundamental either
and if they're not fundamental then they
aren't this true source of causal
power in the universe physical objects
have no cause of powers
it's a useful fiction to think that the
eight ball
being hit by the cue ball um has
there's a causal interaction or that
neurons have causal effects
but it's just a fiction and so that's
why i tied the two together
neurons being objects in space time has
no have no causal powers
my brain causes none of my behavior it
causes none of my experiences
but that that means that therefore
any attempt to show how we solve the
hard problem of consciousness starting
with brain activity and trying to boot
up consciousness will fail
so my idea is simple let's start with
the theory of consciousness and show how
space-time is not fundamental it's just
a data structure within consciousness
that's why space-time isn't fundamental
it's merely a data structure a
visualization tool
that con that consciousness uses to
interact with other consciousnesses
so so i'm the reason so this is all tied
together
the the space time being not fundamental
and the move to make consciousness
fundamental is all part
of one big move recognizing that
that brain activity could not possibly
cause our conscious experiences
so why don't we try the other way let's
start with conscious experiences and
show how they cause
and objects to arise merely as data
structures
within consciousness okay getting to the
neural correlates aspect
you mentioned that it would be to say
that hey because our brain is correlated
with certain conscious experiences
it's that's one thing but then to say
that the brain causes it is another it
would be akin to saying
there's a train track there's a subway
station and people form right before the
train comes
right but it doesn't mean that the
people themselves caused the train to
come
however you just mentioned that there's
transcranial magnetic stimulation
where we can in fact perturb neurons
and then see it would be one thing if we
saw conscious experience
then looked at the neurons and then saw
that there's some association that's
correlation
but then if we can perturb the neurons
to elicit a conscious experience
why is that not evidence for the causal
power going from neurons to
conscious experience great question and
that's what my colleagues would all
point to is that look they'd say
look we can intervene i can literally
manipulate the brain
and get a change in conscious experience
the fact that i can intervene means i'm
showing you
the true causal structure of what's
going on there and that's a logical
error
and it's very easy to see the logical
air imagine you're playing a virtual
reality game and
you're driving a car you're driving a
mustang in a virtual reality game right
and you have a steering wheel and it
turns out you can you can
intervene in that if i turn the steering
wheel to the left my car actually turns
left in the game
if i turn the steering wheel to the
right the car turns right therefore
there must be a real steering wheel and
it must have real causal powers
nope there's no real steering wheel that
that's not that's not the claim well
that's
that might be their claim my claim or my
question
is it is correct to say that the turning
of the steering wheel causes turning in
the game
now it might not be that the turning of
the steering wheel
is akin in causal power to weigh the to
the way that we would think that the
turning of the steering wheel in a
real car changes the wheels and the axes
but all that we need for for causation
to be shown is a implies b
it doesn't matter that they're
intermediate steps
do you understand what i'm saying or am
i not well i'm not explaining it
correctly
well the the thing about the steering
wheel that you see in in the virtual
reality game is that
if you turn your headset to the side
the steering wheel ceases to exist there
is no steering wheel because i'm not
looking at it anymore
the steering when i look back over to
where the steering wheel should be
i see a steering wheel the steering
wheel is something
that i create and destroy as i need it's
gone
now it's back it has no causal powers
the steering wheel
literally has no causal powers it it
informs
me as the player about actions that i
can take
to to interact with the game but the stu
but and the way i
see myself the way i visualize what i'm
doing is i
visualize myself turning the steering
wheel but that's all just a useful
fiction
and the steering wheel itself literally
has no causal powers it's
literally only in my head
there is no external steering wheel with
with causal powers
and i'm saying that that's true not just
in virtual reality but in everyday life
because
space-time is not fundamental it's just
your headset
when you go around in everyday life
think virtual reality
i create the moon when i look up in the
sky
i delete it when i look away there is no
moon just
in the same way that there is no
steering wheel in the virtual reality
game
so when einstein you know asked uh
someone that was with him um do you
really believe the moon is only there
when you look and it's not there when
when no one looks um my answer is yeah
it does it's not there when no one looks
there is no moon
because there is no space time it's and
see that's the part
that einstein wouldn't like right
because his theory was the theory of
space time
space time is not fundamental when we
really understand what that means
nothing inside space-time is fundamental
nothing and therefore nothing inside
space-time has genuine causal powers it
emerges from something deeper
it's a useful fiction that our species
has to think that
physical objects have causal powers i
throw a rock
it hits a window the rock caused the
window to break that's a useful fiction
i inhibit area v4 color disappears
aha therefore v4 causes color it's a
useful fiction but it's just a fiction
just like the steering wheel
in the virtual reality game okay let's
remove the virtual reality let's just
pretend it's a regular game with a tv
screen and you have a controller in
front of you
right and then you move your analog
stick to the left and the character
moves to the left
then would you say that the move that
you moving the analog stick to the left
causes the character to move to the left
yeah in that metaphor now you within
that metaphor you would say that the
the the icon on the screen was the thing
that caused things to move right
so if i saw myself right now like a
paddle hit the thing like in pawn
i hit hit a ball with the no it's really
in that in that metaphor would be the
joystick that was the real thing
but i'm saying once you get that
recognize that
the world around you is just the screen
even the joystick in your head
like the joystick in your hand the
joystick is in your head okay
is in your head itself because space see
that's the real point about what physics
has discovered
space-time is not fundamental it's hard
for us to really grasp that
it's really we so deeply believe
that of course space-time is fundamental
of course the moon is there
when no one looks but when you really
grasp space-time is not fundamental
it and it's actually our construction
then
physical objects don't even exist when
they're not perceived
they don't have causal powers they don't
even exist
you can think of this what i'm doing
right now as
as partly to convince because i already
have a predilection towards your ideas i
already like
you and i like your ideas so you don't
need to convince me too much although i
do have some objections
but i'm i'm demarcating where i feel
people like michael shermer and so on
have problems
because they take that virtual reality
metaphor
and there's some there are some problems
with it because well like i said forget
the virtual reality just imagine a
screen and then you have an analog stick
and then those two get conflated right
okay
there's another problem that i see with
the virtual reality
metaphor when you take off the headset
there is still the computer rendering it
to the lcd
now there are some monitors there are
some virtual reality headsets that
detect when your
forehead is there and then just shut it
off but let's imagine that's not there
then they're like well it still persists
even if when i look to the left it
renders what's on the left or look to
the right it renders
but i can even simulate someone
going through a game without a conscious
perceiver
and then i can set my video camera up to
record that
and that person that character is moving
through the game there is no perceiver
right then and there
that's that's that's why i see this
virtual reality metaphor as having some
limitations but what would you say to
that that look even without a perceiver
i put the headset down it's still
rendering
well um that now in terms of physics
is the question of um
do physical objects literally
exist and have definite values of their
properties
when they're not perceived so that's the
question of
local realism right so local so this is
a technical question
in physics and this is what we're really
addressing here is the question of local
realism
do physical objects really exist and
have definite values
of physical properties like position
momentum and spin when they're not
observed
and is it true that those properties
have effects that propagate no faster
than the speed of light
and you might intuitively think well of
course
the moon has a position it has a
momentum an electron has a position a
momentum
a spin value spin axis when it's not
observed of course
but when we do the experiments um
first you know when this was first
raised you know
einstein was one of the ones who asked
this question back in the epr paper back
in 1935
right and a number of physicists
including wolfgang paulie thought that
this was ludicrous that einstein was
asking a question like you know that was
no more
interesting than how many angels can
dance on the head of a pen how could you
possibly answer einstein's question does
a
an electron have a position a definite
value position or momentum
when it's not observed that's that seems
silly by definition
if you're not observing how could you
tell whether it has a positional
momentum or not
but it when it turned out in 1963 or so
uh the physicist john bell discovered
that we can answer that question you
there is a series of experiments you
know that you can do measurements that
you can do
that will give you certain statistics
that can
allow you to decide whether or not local
realism is true
and that was a real stunning achievement
one of the greatest intellectual
achievements in human history
john bell's inequalities
and and then a year later john bell and
coken and specker
apparently independently also came up
with a way to
to test non-contextual realism
non-contextualism realism is the claim
that
objects exist and have definite values
of their properties when they're not
observed that's
the the realism and the values of those
properties don't depend on the way you
measure them
that's the non-contextual part and
once again quantum theory entails
that non-contextual realism is false
it also entails that local realism is
false and
it's been tested and it's true local
realism is false
and therefore either realism is false
that is that electron has a position
when it's not observed or locality is
false
the influences propagate no faster than
the speed of light or both
and i think that both both are false
local realism is just plain false
non-contextual realism is false and once
we understand that
that means that there right did you say
that non-local realism is also false
uh yeah because space time is not
fundamental so the right
right now space time itself is just i
mean the big
take home is space time is not
fundamental therefore
particles and their properties inside
space-time are not fundamental
for a physicist this is obvious because
um you know
as soon as you say space-time is not
fundamental it's emergent from something
else
well that takes particles with them
because particles are nothing
but irreducible representations of the
symmetries of space-time
the poincare group so particles are
irreducible representations of the
poincare group which are just the
symmetries of space time
the space time's not fundamental neither
are particles so
so my colleagues in cognitive
neurosciences
we're still back thinking that oh we
have this reductionist view space time
is fundamental
you start off with protons and neutrons
or if you're
more sophisticated quarks and leptons
in gluons than gravitons and
those are the elementary particles the
laws that govern them are the
fundamental laws of
of all of reality and we can in a
reductive fashion
fashion build up everything from that
well that whole foundation is gone
space-time is not fundamental those
particles are not fundamental
reductionism is dead space-time
reductionism is dead
we need a completely new framework now
brilliant physicists like neymar connie
hamid going after the amplitude and so
forth
are looking for new foundations for
physics outside of space time
but it's not a reductionist kind of
approach does
nema say that consciousness is
fundamental or
are you just saying well nema has a
theory that simplifies space and time
down to something else
and maybe with your theory the cognitive
the conscious agent theory you can imply
the amplitude of hedron and therefore
you can apply whatever neem is implying
or does not does nima think that
consciousness is fundamental
i i i have no idea what nema thinks
about consciousness
i haven't seen him talk about it myself
in any of his
writings or or lectures um i mean i
would be surprised
if it turned out he thinks consciousness
is fundamental i would be very very
surprised
but i but the right answer is i don't i
don't know what he thinks about that
i would bet good odds that he doesn't
think consciousness is fundamental but
but i don't know i certainly would not
want to ascribe that point of view to
him
all all i've seen from his lectures in
writing is that
there are these beautiful mathematical
structures these positive geometries
amplitude sociohedra
that are that are more fundamental than
space-time
and that in magical ways seem to give
rise to the scattering amplitude so like
two glones hitting each other four
gluons go spraying out
those scattering amplitudes turn out to
be
volumes of these geometric objects he's
finding these positive geometries
but what this new deeper realm is about
i haven't seen him
speculate about you know what is this
telling us
is the realm behind spacetime what is
that realm about i haven't seen him
speculate that he might have some
some speculations but i haven't seen him
he just goes with the math
ask for bell's inequality i'm sure
you're aware that there are some ways
around it
so for example super determinism as well
as a couple others that i can't recall
right now
edwin james he didn't particularly think
bell's inequalities or the experiments
that validate those inequalities
demonstrate that non-realism is is the
way to go
what do you say to those objections well
i i would say
that um the deeper
problems between general relativity and
quantum field theory
that force us to recognize that
space-time isn't fundamental
are the ones that clinch it for me
against realism because
realism about art but entities that are
that are merely representations of space
time
when space time itself is not
fundamental is is is now beside the
point
why what made you choose nema's
amplitude of hedron as opposed to the
other
perhaps simpler models that demonstrate
the space time is emergent
we mentioned a few others before this
call like causal causal dynamic
triangulation there's also spin foam
networks
right um i've been
intrigued in i'm studying nemo's work
because he explains in ways that i
really understand
why we can't really
even have a vestige of space-time as
being fundamental
right so we we can't we can't take one
part of a time
or one part of its space and and try to
boot up the other we
and and and nemo recognizes that we we
also
can't expect that quantum theory is
fundamental
he's saying look it's it's it's deeper
than just space time
we're going to have to have a deeper
framework in which space-time
and quantum theory together
arise joined at the hip and
and so many of the techniques are saying
look what
let's if general relativity
is a you know is not a quantum theory
it's it's a classical theory
it's continuous space and so forth so
maybe what we need to do is let quantum
be fundamental
and then we'll try to somehow quantize
space time and nema is going
far more deep he's saying we need a new
framework in which
locality and space time and
unitarity of quantum theory
arise together from something that's
neither local in space-time and
non-unitary and that's
i think so i'm going i'm going after
nema
um partly because i think that he makes
a good case that that space-time and
quantum theory
both have to emerge from something
deeper and that we really need them
we need to bite the bullet and recognize
we can't go halfway we need
to go really a radical new foundation
the constraint on the new foundation of
course is that it has to give rise to
space time and quantum theory in ways
that we know and love and in particular
it has to give
the only observable
of quantum gravity in our space in
an asymptotically flat space time like
ours the only observable
that there is is scattering amplitude
the scouting objects that's the only
observer there are no local observables
and
nemo explains that so so when we look at
how to get the only
observable in asymptotically flat space
time
what i'm asking is that there are
several contenders to
fundamental theories of everything which
they have to be fundamental theory of
everything
but there there are several and i'm glad
that you're pursuing
nema's amplitude of hedron because i'm
also interested in how consciousness can
give rise to some of those other
potential theories of everything and i
only have a finite amount of time
so i'm glad that you're doing it but i'm
curious as to why you chose that one
the criteria you just said which is qft
and general relativity have to come
from something else and you would prefer
that not
be embedded within space time but in
fact have some other structure that
gives rise to space time
but there are quite a there are quite a
few for example
i just have a list here and i'm just
curious why you chose
the amplitude of heatron other than you
have to start somewhere so for example
wolfram's theory of everything
which starts with computation which
seems so similar to yours actually we
can get to that later
and there's pati salaam there's sl-10
there is e8
as well right right right and there's
strand model
from christopher schiller there's also
one more frightens
frightens frighten his name is bernard
royd friden
he believes that the the laws of
physics i believe can be unified under
fischer information so they're purely
informational
at their base i'm curious why nemo's
as opposed to those that i just listed
well there's there's a couple reasons
one is i'm convinced
by nemo's argument that scattering
amplitudes aren't
are the only observable and
his is the only theory that predicts
from first principles
the exact scattering amplitudes and
shows deep symmetries behind those
scattering amplitudes
right and that also you know
explains why when we look at these
deeper symmetries outside of space time
um hundreds or thousands of pages of
computation that you get
from fineman diagrams on the scattering
amplitudes turns into two or three terms
so so he's got the beef he's actually
he starts with something outside of
space-time he gives rise to quantum
theory unitarity
and locality and the the precise phi
cube theory fight of the four theory um
yang mills super yang mills gravit
he's getting one after another he's
getting these scattering amplitudes
he's got the beef these other theories
are you know
saying we can do this we can do this
he's doing it i see in other words he's
the closest so far
yeah he's the closest and then there's
one other thing that that also
is is making me pursue this and that is
i'm starting with this theory of
markovian kernels this this dynamical
system of conscious agents
now markovian kernels in general are not
associated with positive geometries
right and nema's saying this deeper
structure is positive geometries
but and this is what i'm working with my
mathematician
uh colleague chaitan prakash and and
others
on i claim and we're
and we'll see if i'm right i claim that
the asymptotic
and invariant behavior of markovian
systems
is identified with positive geometries
so even though the step-by-step dynamics
repeat that one more time repeat that
one more time the so so
when you have a markovian system right
you have the step-by-step dynamics but
you can also
ask what happens long term if you look
at the long the broads
okay broad view technically i have a
markovian kernel p
i'm looking at p to the end
which is p composed with p composed of p
n times as n goes to infinity
those kernels i claim are are
invariably associated with positive
geometries without adding more structure
that's all you need p to the n if you
take
kernel p p to the n will be associated
with positive geometry as n goes to
infinity
okay that's interesting i gotta i gotta
think about that
one of your papers with your friend your
i love this guy for prakash
right yeah i haven't had a chance to
look at any of his papers that weren't
co-authored with you though either way
one of the papers
a recent one was showing that the payoff
functions
that are homomorphic to totally ordered
sets as well as permutation groups
cyclic groups
and one other right if you take their
number
and you divide it by the total amount
that's admissible
that it tends to zero and for the people
listening
what i've what i hear from you is saying
that therefore the probability that we
see
reality as it is is zero but
i don't know if that was but but i see
that as a leap so i must be missing a
step
because the leap is that there's a
hidden claim
you can go from the total size of the
set of admissible
functions over the sorry
under as the denominator of the total
functions that are homomorphic to
certain groups and certain structures
that's fine you can say that that goes
to zero but then you have to say
that there's an even probability
distribution that we could have gotten
any one of them for you to say that the
probability then
as n goes to infinity of us seeing truth
or reality as it is or homomorphic to
the structure
is also zero excellent point so this is
a very technical point but it's an
important one
so so in evolutionary theory the fitness
payoff functions
depend on the state of the world
whatever objective reality might be it
depends on that
but it also depends on the organism its
state its action and the competitors and
so forth
so it's a complicated function with a
very complicated domain
including the state of the world and the
range of the function
are the payoff values you may like from
one to n
if they're n you know payoff values and
of course evolutionary theory
evolutionary game theory
is saying that our we're tuned our
senses will be tuned to the payoffs
right
in other words organisms that
uh better perceive how to get high
payoffs are the ones that are going to
survive so it's our senses will be tuned
to the payoffs
so the question then the technical
question is what is the probability that
the payoff functions
preserve information about the structure
of the world say the world has a group
structure
or total order um and i ask what is the
probability that a payoff function will
will preserve that structure you know
and we looked at two kinds of symmetry
groups and total orders and also
measurable structures
and in what we did is we used
just we assumed a discrete set of states
on the world
a finite set of states and a finite set
of payoff values so like
you know n states in the world
m states of the payoff values and
and then what we can do is literally
using combinatorical
combinatorial arguments count the number
of payoff functions that preserve
the structure like the group structure
and divide as you say by the total
number which is a finite number this is
a finite number
of total payoff functions and
there of course counting measure
literally counting the number of
functions
is the canonical measure and then we
take the limit as the
number of states in the world and the
number of payoff values
goes to infinity now now someone could
argue as
raised the question that you just raised
why is counting measure the measure that
we used
why should there be some other measure
and the answer is that
evolutionary theory gives us no argument
for any other measure
so if someone wants to say we use the
wrong measure
then the burden of proof is on them to
say what is the new measure
and on principled evolutionary grounds
what is the measure that we should use
instead of counting measure and why
and that will be a brand new addition to
the theory of evolution of natural
selection
good luck well what if the
extra condition doesn't come from
evolutionary theory but instead
classical physics like people like nema
or even michael shermer might think
which is saying that okay there is
a probability distribution that favors
certain structure preservedness for
whatever reason much like we don't know
why the fundamental laws are the way
they are now of course you're saying
well i can derive the fundamental laws
forget that because i'm going to another
model them saying that the fundamental
laws are fundamental
and one of them is that the probability
distribution of your perceptions
will tend not necessarily tend to but
they're not uniform
absolutely and and i if someone can do
that
fabulous that would destroy our theorem
so
so that's that's the challenge you could
think of our theorem
as putting out that challenge come up
with some new principle that explains
why
there's a bias toward payoff functions
that are homomorphic to the structure of
reality what is
the conspiracy in nature that makes that
happen
there's i mean evolution by natural
selection this is currently formulated
and physics says it's currently
formulated
gives us no belief that there's a
conspiracy
going on to make the homomorphic
functions more probable
but if someone can come up with a theory
that explains why
nature conspires that way i'm i'll be
the first to
to listen very intently by the way do
you also have a measure
of structure preservedness that isn't a
strict
homomorphism because if okay
just for people listening in the way
that it's written
that i saw from the paper that that you
published recently is
it's like you have one two three four
five imagine that's a totally order set
one two three four five and that's how
the world is
but if someone sees the world as one two
three four five
four i'd be like nope no you're not
seeing the world as it is
but yet it's still similar right so you
can use things like the l2 norm or the l
infinity norm to to look at how many
so for you could say suppose that here's
a payoff function that's
that's purely homomorphic we can ask how
many
payoff functions are within a certain
distance like an l2 distance or an l
infinity distance
of that payoff function and we can for
each
distance that we look at we can ask how
many
payoff functions even though if they're
not exactly homomorphic are that close
to homomorphism
and then we can look at the ratio of
those to all payoff and see
again if they go to zero or not um and
and so in the case of total orders
um it turns out that
if you allow a very very
generous width like i think there's like
20
variation sure um the set of payoff
functions
that were within 20 variation of of any
homomorphic function still went to zero
in the case of um
symmetric groups that was not true um
if you allowed just a small window
around
the the homowork functions then most of
them
then it would they would have full
weight so most functions were
most payoff functions were very close to
a function which was homomorphic
to um you know for automorphism of the
symmetry
same thing for measurable structures in
measurable structures
almost every function was close to
a payoff function that is homomorphic
but
but notice that that won't buy you
anything
because there are
countless structures that
nature might have countless
the fact that a random function a
randomly chosen pail function
is close to a symmetric something that's
homomorphic
a symmetry preserving function also a
measurable function
you could now give me thousands of
different
kinds of homomorphisms it's close to
well
which one is natural selection choosing
to shape you to
there are a random function is is close
to all of these
where is the where's the selection
pressure to push you toward one or the
other
in other words all you get is that
yeah a randomly chosen fail function you
could show us it's it's
close to lots of different things that
are homomorphic to all else
but where's the selection pressure there
there's no selection pressure there at
all
yeah now let's one more
critique is that gravity is not a cyclic
group
it's not a totally ordered set it's not
a permutation group
it's not a measure well maybe but but
either way the structure of the
fundamental physics coming from a
different frame that is where
consciousness is not fundamental
it doesn't follow what i've seen so far
i think you've done totally ordered
permutations cyclic and measurable
spaces
right but it's not as if the fundamental
laws or the fundamental space of being
from the materialist point of view
are those so what you're counting isn't
necessarily reality per se it could be
it could be
but right it's not as if as far as we
know and the lagrangian is a condition
on that
and it's not as if the lagrangian is a
cyclical group so right
so so
fair point okay so why is so why does
that
does what you've studied demonstrate
anything about reality right
so yeah so i think a good
argument against our paper is we we've
looked at four different structures
and we showed in each case that the
probability is zero that um a randomly
chosen payoff function would be a
homomorphism
and what we want
is a paper that proves that for any
possible structure
right not just the four structures that
we looked at we don't have that theorem
yet
so someone could come along and say look
we have independent evidence that this
is the structure of the world and we can
prove that for that structure of the
world
payoff almost every payoff function is a
homomorphism of that structure so
we're throwing down that ghana we're
saying for you
for someone to argue that natural
selection will of course
favor vertical perceptions seeing the
truth of the true structure of the world
then what you have to do you it's it's
not obvious that that's the case
here's four counter examples we give
four counter examples right total orders
so here are four counter examples so so
it's not just obviously true that that's
going to happen for the structure of the
world so you now
to convince me that natural selection
favors vertical perceptions you have to
tell me exactly the structure of the
world
and prove that in fact the homomorphisms
have
full measure so so we've thrown the
gauntlet down
all of my colleagues almost all of my
colleagues in cognitive neuroscience who
study perception
have just assumed that of course natural
selection favors vertical perception
we gave four counter examples and we're
basically throwing down the gauntlet to
our field and saying
if you believe that you you need to come
up with a beef where is the beef
what is the structure of the world that
would have full measure
for the homomorphisms if you can't do
that then then
what is the conspiracy in the laws of
nature
that would so in other words what we've
done is thrown down the gauntlet
in some sense we're saying hey the
burden of proof is now on the person
who claims that evolution is going to
shape vertical perceptions
here for here are four counter examples
give us an example of where it possibly
could
and good luck because here's why they're
not going to
succeed to be a homomorphism
a function has to satisfy some strict
equations
most functions don't satisfy them end of
proof
it's just that simple good luck but but
so we've thrown down the gauntlet
that the argument i just gave you is
going to be the heart
of a deeper theory a deeper paper that
will that we hope to get
in which we just proved that no matter
what yeah i'm excited about that
right have you pursued category theory
that's what works as far as
like the most abstract of all the
mathematical theories that's where we're
headed exactly right category theorem
inside
okay cool cool i just said with category
three right
what about partially ordered sets not as
if even if you proved in the partially
ordered set
case it's like okay that's it's yeah
we'd like to do partial orders and also
topologies
right so those are some obvious big ones
so if we can't get the full category
i mean we'd like to get the full
category theory um proof
that just basically says you got a
structure in the world your payoff
functions won't preserve it almost
surely and destroy that's what we want
we've got only four examples um and then
we've got this
high level argument that i gave you that
to be a homomorphism you have to satisfy
these equations so good luck
most won't be so that suggests to me
that there's
going to be probably a very simple
category theoretic
proof of this thing uh and that will
take care of it
or perhaps you find the one structure
maybe there's even one or two structures
a finite amount
that's satisfied that the vertical
perception and then from that you're
like okay
that's interesting that's uniqueness
among all the structures and therefore
something special and maybe we can imply
the laws of physics from that either way
would be interesting
oh absolutely so you know i don't care
how it comes out
um i i just want to pursue and see what
see what does come out right
but what i am saying is this way too
fast my colleagues thinking oh of course
natural selection
favors two percent oh that's way way too
fast
why do they think that if they come from
an evolutionary background
because evolution just is all about what
works
and what works who cares about what's
true true in the in the materialist
sense
i agree and i should say um there are
many of my colleagues and friends like
steve pinker
a good colleague and long time friend
who clearly understands
that natural selection does not
in general favor true beliefs right and
he's got a brilliant paper
um a published um called
so how does the mind work it's a
wonderful paper so if you look up steve
pinker so how does the mind work
he he gives in that paper five good
reasons for
why evolution will not lead us to have
true
beliefs in general um
and also real robert trevors has
argued you know brilliantly on
evolutionary grounds that there are
reasons why we should be deeply
self-deceived we the best
liar the best the most convincing liar
in social situations is the one who
believes his own lie
and so there are selection pressures for
us to be deeply deceived
now in trevor's case however he then
even though he understands that aspect
of evolution and
leading to false beliefs when it came to
perception
trevors still believed and wrote
that seeing the structure of reality as
it is would make you more fit
and that's the argument that most people
believe it's
the argument goes like this those of our
ancestors
who saw reality more accurately
had a competitive advantage over those
who saw the world less accurately
a new competitive advantage in the you
know the the basic
activities of life feeding fighting
fleeing and mating right and therefore
those who saw more accurately were more
likely to pass on their genes
that code for the more accurate
perceptions
and therefore we can be quite confident
that we may not see all of the truth
but we see those aspects of the truth
that we need to survive
and that kind of argument completely
persuades most of my
my colleagues it apparently persuaded
trivers because he he wrote that you
know yeah it's more fit to see reality
as it is
it didn't persuade pinker although
pinker in the in that paper that i
the brilliant paper that i mentioned you
know so how does the mind work
he does at the at the end of his
discussion of the five
reasons uh why evolution wouldn't
lead to to true beliefs he does make an
exception for everyday middle-sized
objects
and for the quotidian beliefs of of our
friends the everyday quotation beliefs
are
so he he he doesn't explain why he makes
those exceptions
but he does make those two exceptions
and so i'm really focusing on that
exception about everyday middle-sized
objects yeah i'm saying
that our perception of everyday
middle-sized objects
is also not an example of a true belief
it's just an example of something as you
said that's
fit enough to keep you alive uh okay
well this is a question
more about evolutionary modeling in
general
and please forgive me as i verbally
fumble through this because i haven't my
thoughts on this aren't
fully developed are fitness payoffs as
simple as just
a one-dimensional case so for example
some issue that i an issue that i have
with utilitarians
is that they will project pleasure and
pain down to one dimensional axis
which to me neglects that there are
different kinds of pleasures or that you
can combine
pleasure and pain or that there are
different kinds of pain
now
this means to me that projecting onto
the real line is either not possible
or it's not trivial or it's not useful
and i've always wondered the same
about fitness payoffs i see something
similar happening so perhaps fitness
is a complex multi-dimensional space and
the choice between any given two points
in order for you to make it you need to
employ a metric or norm and then that
would need to be justified
in other words do you have do you see
any problems with fitness payoffs being
real r1 to r1 uh well
yes i do and the the reason
is that the domain need not be r1
the domain could be as high dimensional
as you want or the very notion of
dimension may not even apply
so but but you sticking with you know
the domain having
it could be you know a 50 dimensional
image going down to r1
yeah so going down to r1 now
fitness in terms of evolution is very
very simple
do you have more kids in the competition
end of story
that's r1 so the but
what you were talking about though the
pain and pleasure and so forth
the the kinds of emotions that we may
evolve
to guide our behaviors in an
evolutionary theory could be as
complicated as you want
right so so the payoff is
reproductive success that's it that's
the only payoff that there is
we we we will talk about you know payoff
functions as
like points in the game but ultimately
the idea is that
you you gather the number of points you
get in playing the game is really
translated into how many kids do you
have how many genes do you pass on so
that's why in evolutionary theory
the the domain can be as complicated as
you want
the range is r1 kids
what is it's not the absolute number of
kids it all that matters is that you
have more than the competition right so
it's not like it you have to be perfect
or anything like that it's just a
satisficing solution
so so we have to distinguish the
payoff value which is
reproductive success versus all the
complicated emotions
that will guide our behaviors to get
enough payoff value right
so so so we don't want to conflate those
two things so evolutionary theory allows
you to have as complicated a set of
emotions and
motivations as as you want very very
complicated
the payoff value is r1
i got it all right thanks man i
appreciate that we're gonna have to
schedule another call if you don't mind
no you're asking um it's fun for me
because this is far more technical than
most um questions so and uh it's it's
enjoyable
i i just hope that your audience will be
able to follow this is probably
some of them won't be able to but that's
fine i feel like most people
one of the reasons why i've been
successful to the degree that i have
is that people are watching more because
i as an interviewer i'm engaged like i'm
asking questions that i want to know the
answer to
right rather than what i think the
audience cares about and there's a bit
of a
facade there on manufacturing good well
well
i think for a certain audience then
these are the right questions absolutely
for
any i mean you're asking the right
questions for anybody that really knows
their math and science
and it must be hard knows about you
you're asking exactly the right
questions
thanks man i i appreciate that you know
like it gets a bit more technical like
like why did you why are you choosing
the geometric algebra with the signature
one three
and then saying that implies space time
because because that to me is
putting extra structure on but okay well
we can get to that later
all right i'm gonna have to i don't
recall exactly where we left off but
it's all right i'll put intermission and
people will understand if there's a
change in topic
sure okay how's it going donald
i'm doing great how about you kurt good
man okay you were just mentioning that
some of your practices of meditation are
intense
and they usually are today was
particularly intense or
average intensity just average but it's
always pretty intense
it's um okay what do you see what
happens during it
well it's
it's going into the unknown letting go
of all thoughts
and there's innate fear
of the unknown and
so facing that fear and letting it go
can be can be very very intense just so
if you you know tried
just sitting for 10 minutes
with absolutely no thoughts just being
in the moment you'll find that thoughts
just come up and they
invade and and and
if you let them go and and go back into
quiet you'll see the thoughts just keep
coming back
up and and but when you actually go into
a space where
you do let go of thoughts and it is
it's utter silence then
it starts to appear that those thoughts
are part of a defense mechanism
that they're they're they're hiding
uh behind them uh a good deal of um
fear of the unknown and yeah we're
always you know
one thing about our species is that we
build models of our environment
and we rely on our models to protect us
right we predict
you know some some creatures don't build
models
or or don't very build very
sophisticated models of their
environment
and their strategy is like you know with
back some bacteria
you just multiply multiply multiply and
and
um that's that's how you survive you
know just
vast multiplication our species is
different we have
very few kids and um
we have a big cerebral cortex a frontal
lobe that's building models
of of our environment and we're
simulating what will happen
um and so that we you know in the
simulation something goes wrong we see
oh i shouldn't do that
instead of sacrificing our bodies we
sacrifice our virtual body in the
simulation right
and we learn so when you start letting
go of all of your thoughts
you're letting go of this very deeply
ingrained
protective mechanism that we have of
building models and and
analyzing things and looking into the
future and
running through scenarios and so forth
it's one of the great strengths of our
species
it's all a big difference
do you feel like all our thoughts are
defense mechanisms
well uh no but
it's it's pretty much like this it's
it's like um
if we look at eating
we all have to eat and so it's a
necessary part of life to to eat
but but if um
you decide that you know you're gonna
you know you've had lunch and you're
just going to
do something else but you find that you
can't stop thinking about food and you
keep walking over to the refrigerator
and you get that well that's that's
different that's that's now something
healthy that's turned into an obsession
it's a problem right
and it's the same thing with thoughts
thoughts are great we use them to go to
the moon
we use them to build all this technology
we use them to cure disease
they're wonderful but if you find
that when you say okay you know thought
is a great tool but for the next 10
minutes
i would just like to relax without any
thoughts and then you find you can't do
it
you find that these thoughts invade and
that when you
let go of the thoughts and you just go
into pure silence
that um you're afraid
and you retreat back into the thoughts
well that that suggests that
um just like in the case of of the food
right there's a useful
usage of food and it's very very
necessary
but there's a case where it becomes an
obsession and there's a problem
same thing with thought it's a great
tool but but when you can't let go of
thought for 10 minutes
in it and the thoughts invade and you
find that going into the
silence triggers um an innate fear
then you know that there's something
else that's going on and so
so in the meditation it's it's a matter
of
for me facing the silence
and the fears that come up um without
judgment without condemnation without
trying just being
being with that and just watching that
whole amazing process to
is sort of finding out wow i didn't know
that this was part of me i just was
living in my thoughts
i had no idea that it would be so hard
to let go of thoughts so it's nothing
wrong about thoughts
but when they're obsessive then that's a
different thing
and in the case the analogy with the
fridge and the food
it's me it's an obsession when it
becomes maladaptive
is that what you're defining as
obsession right yeah so
you can't your thoughts are always about
the refrigerator and getting the next
food and you find yourself gaining tons
of tons of weight and to the point where
you have heart disease and things like
that
right you know that's at some point you
realize okay well maybe i've got
uh you know food is necessary but but
too much food and too much thinking
about food is food is a sign of
of something maladaptive um
okay you also mentioned in the case
against reality that illusions are a
failure to guide adaptive behavior
i don't know if you mentioned that
quoting someone else or if you mention
that
and because you believe it and either
way do you agree with that statement or
disagree yeah i i do agree with that
that that
um and it was sort of a statement that i
was making
in contrast to what most of my
colleagues in in perception science
would say most of my colleagues would
say that an elite
is a perception that fails to match
reality
right so i see a stick in the water it
looks bent
but the stick isn't bent so my
perception fails to match the reality i
see something that looks bent but the
stick isn't bent
right that kind of thing and
i'm suggesting on evolutionary grounds
well i'm claiming
that the theory of evolution entails
mathematically
that the probability that any of our
perceptions
in any way match the structure of
reality is zero
in other words none of our perceptions
tell us truths about the structure of
objective reality according to
evolutionary theory
that's just are you aware of the various
notions of truth such as correspondence
and deflationary and pragmatic
sure absolutely so so most
most of my colleagues are taking a
correspondence notion right
they're saying that that i see
a red apple
that's because in fact in objective
reality there is something with that
that shape and that color that would
continue to exist even if no one were
there to perceive it and so there's
a correspondence no one thinks it's
perfect correspondence we don't see
all of the structure of objective
reality but but the
idea of truth that i'm talking about is
reality
whatever it is has certain structures to
it
topologies perhaps
group structures metrics whatever it
might be whatever the structures of
reality are
and our perceptions then
tell us truths about those structures
some of the structures of our
perceptions are
matching the structures of objective
reality the structure of the shape of
the apple that we perceive
is homomorphic to the structure that the
apple really has
and so forth and that's what i'm saying
evolutionary theory contradicts
now are you taking more of a pragmatic
stance on the definition of truth
i'm not um
so what's what's interesting is when i
talk about
if you don't mind just for the audience
do you mind defining
the difference between correspondence
and then pragmatic and then where you
defer from pragmatic
as far as i can tell it sounds like
yours is pragmatic because it's
about adaptive behavior so i'm curious
to know where the difference is
right so in the correspondence theory of
truth the
the idea is that um there is an
objective reality that has
a definite state a definite structure
and to see truly to perceive truly
is to have the structures of your
perception
be homomorphic to at least
some of the structures in objective
reality so to to preserve those
structures
um a
pragmatist would would say
that's not possible we there are no
true perceptions of that kind all we can
ask of our perceptions
is do they work
so do our concepts work do our
perceptions work
and you know and what i'm saying is that
from an evolutionary point of view
the theory of evolution gives us
no reason to believe that our cognitive
or perceptual systems were shaped
to give us the correspondence kinds of
truths
no reason now that doesn't mean that
evolutionary theory is true i i
write i my attitude about scientific
theories is is
very very pragmatic in the following
sense i don't think that any of our
scientific theories are true
including mine but they're the best
tools that we have so far
and so what we do as scientists is to
very carefully study
these tools we study evolution by
natural selection we study
general relativity we study quantum
field theory and we
see what these theories entail because
not because they're the final answer
they're not i don't think any good
scientists think so the final answer
is they're they're the answers we've got
so far the the
the tools that we have so far so
i'm saying that evolution by natural
selection absolutely entails
that none of our perceptions correspond
to a true structure of an objective
reality
now does that mean that i'm a pragmatist
no i'm just telling you what
evolutionary theory entails that's all
that's done so i'm just being very very
hard-nosed this is what the theory
entails we've got theorems about it if
someone wants to argue i can show
my theorem and they can we can argue
about the theorems but now once i've
said that about evolutionary theory i
can step back and say is there a deeper
point of view that i would like to take
in which i still argue for a
correspondence theory of truth
and i'm i'm absolutely open to a deeper
point of view
in which there is a correspondence
theory of truth whatever that deeper
point of view is though and this is the
interesting and tricky part about it
whatever deeper point of view i take
it better be the case that i can explain
why within space and time
and evolution by natural selection that
those theories
entail only a pragmatic view
of perceptions not a truth view
so if i'm going to take a deeper point
of view in which i say there is a
correspondence theory of truth
then for that to work i have to be able
to explain
why such a successful theory as
evolution by natural selection and is
spectacularly successful
why that theory entails a pragmatic view
of our perceptions and our cognitive
abilities they're all pragmatic not not
about truth
and so that's so that's sort of the
subtlety of of this point of view a lot
of people will will
contradict or or you know critique what
i'm saying on on two counts they'll say
first how in the world can you
say that we don't see the truth about
the world
do you know what the truth about reality
is if you don't know what the truth
about reality is then how could you ever
know
that we don't see it okay that's the
first argument
and and the reply is
and this is the power of mathematical
models like evolution by natural
selection
that mathematical model entails that
whatever the structure of objective
reality is
it we don't need to propose that we know
what the structure objective really is
whatever it is the probability is zero
that natural selection would shape us to
see it
so the nice thing about that answer is i
don't need
to guess or know what objective reality
is
to know that evolution by natural
selection entails
that whatever the reality is we don't
see it we don't perceive it
okay so so that the first objection is
is a very natural objection by the way
right how could you know that we don't
see reality because you don't know
reality
is well the answer is the mathematics is
so sophisticated
it's allowing you to say that whatever
reality is you don't see it
without ever claiming to know what
reality is
the the second point then is that you
know
often people will say well you know so
you've just said
that none of our perceptions none of our
cognitive capacities are about the truth
and then you try to come up with a model
of objective reality right this theory
of conscious agents and so forth
well and indeed i am and and that's
because
i don't take evolution by natural
selection as the final word
is just a tool that tool entails a
pragmatic view
great that's what that tool entails i
would like to get a deeper view
in which consciousness is fundamental
and from that deep review
show how space time emerges as
an interface representation of this
deeper reality
and show within that interface why
the dynamics of this deeper realm looks
at least in certain cases like evolution
by natural selection and why
it looks like the kind of structure that
we see in evolutionary theory
so so evolution of natural selection
will be a constraint on any deeper
theory of reality that i propose
any deeper theory when it projects into
space time
it better look like general relativity
quantum field theory
evolution of natural selection when you
project it into space time
or improvements on those theories
but not less than those theories you
know it it
has to explain everything those theories
explain and more within space time
so so but and this is maybe subtle for
those who
who aren't scientists but this is just
standard i mean what i'm saying here is
is just the standard view of scientists
we take our theories not as the truth
just the best accounts that we have so
far the best tools that we have
so far a good theory will tell you where
it stops
where it fails but no no
and by the way general relativity and
quantum field theory
very very clearly tell us that they fail
that space time itself
is only an emerging concept it cannot be
fundamental
and so the very foundations of quantum
field theory which is
fields on space time and the very nature
of general relativity which is
the dynamics of space time
can't be fundamental so those theories
are good enough to tell us
that despite their successes they're not
the final answer there's something
deeper but they can't tell us
what that deeper thing is and that's
where the creativity
of the of the scientific endeavor kicks
in
it's up to the scientists to take a leap
of imagination what deeper notion
of reality what deeper theoretical
structures can we come up with
that would project down
into what we call space-time and in that
projection they would look like general
relativity they would look like quantum
field therian
and evolution by natural selection
what's the deeper dynamics in this
deeper realm that would project
into that and so there
our current theories can only give us
very very
loose guidance there's a lot of creative
imagination
that then is required to go into this
deeper realm and
and that's where the most creative
scientists of course want to go
it's it's great fun when we find a hole
in our current theories and get the
chance
to discover something new and so that's
that's the fun part of it now when it
comes to space and time i've heard you
describe it as a data compression tool
for us conscious agents
why do we need as conscious agents data
compression why is there a limit to how
much we can process
well that's going to be a very
interesting
thing for this deeper theory to to try
to explain
why is there this limit it
it may be that all conscious
systems are necessarily finite
and that's one theory that i'm playing
with that the
the realm of conscious agents may be
such that
there is no bound to the complexity that
a conscious agent can have
but it's but it's always finite so it's
as big as you wish but but always finite
and in which case no matter how complex
you are compared
to all the possible complexity your
measure zero your probability zero right
you have
so so in that sense
if but but there may be a really really
deep
point of view in which consciousness
may be taking these
dividing itself into sort of
subconsciousnesses which are sort of
different perspectives
that are looking at the whole and these
different perspectives would necessarily
then have limited
information about the whole they'll only
be able to see through an interface but
necessarily
right this is it's sort of the kind of
thing like right
in the twitterverse i can
it's a there's tens of millions of users
billions of tweets
i could talk with one or two twitter
users extensively and
follow all of their tweets maybe if i
really into it maybe
a hundred of them and follow all their
tweets but there's
10 million or more twitter users so i ca
there's no way
there's absolutely no way so if i want
to get a
feel for what's happening in general in
the twitterverse
i'm going to need to have some kind of
data compression tool some visualization
tool
right we see this all the time whenever
whenever there's big
social media data we use visualization
tools to see what's going on
and that's what i think space time is
space time
is our headset we've mistaken the
headset for reality we've assumed that
space and time are fundamental or space
time is fundamental
we've assumed that that's subjective
reality and it's just a rookie mistake
it's our headset it's our visualization
tool
and what what's behind it is this vast
network of other conscious agents
now it's one thing for me to say this it
sounds you know
interesting but where's the beef and
where the beef is going to have to come
from
is a precise mathematical description of
the dynamics of conscious agents
so it's for those interested in the math
it's
dynamics on networks so it's network
theory
so the kind of stuff that you use when
you're studying like the internet and
um the dynamics of information flow on
the internet and so forth there's that
kind of mathematics
so it's it's it's proposing a specific
mathematical dynamics
on a network of conscious agents
then the way i think it'll go is that
the asymptotic behavior
of that dynamics which is that
that just means you can't see every
single tweet
you can't interact with every single
user but you can see the long-term
trends
what are the things that are trending
long-term what are the big
picture kinds of that's what i mean by
the asymptotics what what happens
if you look at it over a long period of
time what are the like the patterns over
a long period of time
and i think that that is
what is behind space time and and in
modern physics what they're seeing what
with the physicists right now
when they try to get structures beyond
space-time
you know they're trying to take the next
step beyond space-time
they they are seeing some interesting
structures called positive geometries
amplitude sociohedra and so forth these
positive geometries
i want the direction i'm going is to
show that those positive geometry
structures that they're coming up with
are representations of the asymptotic
behavior
of this dynamics of conscious agents and
if i can do that
then i will be able to use their work
and pull the thread all the way from a
theory of conscious agents and their
dynamics
through the asymptotics of that into
these positive geometries that they
found
and then they tell you how to go from
that to the actual
prediction of scattering events like at
the large hadron collider
so that's my goal the beef will be if i
can start with a theory of consciousness
look at it at its asymptotics and show
that the asymptotics of that theory
consciousness
through this route that the physicists
have found already leads to the
scattering amplitudes
that we can then test at the at the
large hadron collider that's where we
have the beef
space and time aren't fundamental in
your theory
is cause it's causality fundamental um
certainly not causality in space and
time right so when we think about
causality
we think about for example the um the
cue ball hitting the eight ball and
making a crane into the corner pocket
and or we think about
uh neurons in the brain causing our
behaviors and causing our experiences
and and so i flat out deny
that anything in space-time
has any causal powers can you help me
something i'm working on is a definition
of causality it turns out it's extremely
elusive even though it seems like it's
it's intuitive the closer you look the
more slippery it gets
how are you defining causality in your
theory
so you're absolutely right in fact there
are there's the
what there's there's a handbook of
causality
a bunch of philosophers and and others
talking about causality of the oxford
handbook of causality or something like
that
if you read through it there are
many many different views on causality
and there is no agreed upon
universal definition of causality
mathematically
in computer science when we
when we talk about causality some of the
best work there
is based on the notion of directed
acyclic graphs
judea pearl professor at ucla
and his students and many collaborators
have been modeling causality
whatever it is as directed acyclic
graphs but i think that even judea pearl
um doesn't hazard definition of
causality right
he it's it's much like how do you define
if you're in geometry how do you define
a point well it's it's sort of a
primitive concept you
you but two of them make a line right
two of them define a line and so you
start
so for for many scientific theories the
notion of causality
is a primitive it's a place where
explanation
stops and
and that's not a unique problem to the
notion of causality
every scientific theory
must stop at some point it can't explain
everything
there will be some primitive notions and
this is unavoidable
so there are no scientific theories that
explain everything
every scientific theory will have some
handful
hopefully as small as possible of
primitive notions
that where you just say you know like if
you have a little kid that says but what
why is that you tell them and say but
but how come that and then so
at some point you just say it it just is
right your theory just stops and says
that's just the way it is and so so for
causality
we you know we tend to think of
causality well
if i can intervene in
some system and then change things
change
as a result of my intervention that's a
proof of causality
but that turns out not to work um
you can get counter examples to that um
what about causes always perceive their
facts well
you can have you can
set up thought experiments where that
where the the effects
um don't perceive the causes but where
there's yes right so that's the reason
why
i forget the person's name pearl you
mentioned jay pearl right
that's why he said acyclic because he
doesn't want
the causes to proceed effect or because
he doesn't want it to
to get to some place where you cause
yourself
right yeah once once you get cycles it
gets pretty complicated and the notion
of causality
would start to slip through your fingers
things where you were in everyday life
you see cycles
you can you can unwrap them as an ever
extending
directed acyclic graph so you can just
take the time parameter instead of
cycling back you go to new states
downward so
ways to to avoid cycles even in what we
in everyday life
think of as as cyclic behavior so i
would say that
causality you're you're right to pick
on it it's the the best and brightest
when i look at i think it's the oxford
handbook of causality
wonderful articles brilliant thinkers
and they
disagree they don't know so there's no
received opinion about what causality is
and is there one that you feel like
is getting closest close to the truth
um
i'll tell you why i asked all these
yeah all the ones i saw there um i think
that they all were were touching
different parts of
the elephant in interesting ways right
but but that
um it may be that ultimately causality
is one of these primitives like points
in geometry
okay when you say that reality is
innately objective
so there's the w the world state x g
experience so that's like the conscious
agent then
i assume what you're saying is objective
reality is the w
the world state and the agents right
then later you do this i love this you
then take
well w could also be composed of
different conscious agents
and then we can have a string of them
why are you calling that
objective to me and this just might be
semantics
i hear that as subjective given that
it's a conscious agent
that is it's a subject all the way
through the chain
right if it was just if you were like
hey there's one world or there's a few
but w
is not dependent on other causal
necessary conscious agents
then i could see using the term
objective why is it that you still use
the term
objective when we can extend the graph
to just conscious agents right so
so the the proposal is
that what the universe is
fundamentally is a vast network of
interacting conscious agents
so when i say that that's the objective
truth of course each agent is a subject
right each agent is a conscious entity
but what i'm saying is that even
when i'm asleep the network
still exists that's all so even if i'm
sound asleep and i'm not having any
conscious experiences or anything like
that
the the the eye that's talking to you
right now
the that that network of conscious
agents
is just like a twitter user right um
whether or not i happen to be
reading tweets or sending tweets the
twitterverse exists
it's out there even though really the
twitter verse is just a bunch of other
subjects people people tweeting
intersubjectivity
implies the objectivity that's right
and and and specifically the fact that
it's
it still exists even if i
don't perceive it okay we're going to
get philosophical there
i was going to get to this later but now
that we're here how
what's the i in this conscious agent
model right
so in the conscious agent model the
notion of a self
is not fundamental so conscious agents
are just these mathematical structures
that have experiences
i'll make decisions and then act on
those decisions
but the notion of a self is not
fundamental
a self is something that a network of
conscious agents can build
so it can be a an experience
dead okay i might stop you every once in
a while to clarify just for myself
you're saying that a self is a
conglomeration of
conscious agents it's a data structure
that they build
does that mean that right now i'm
talking to donald
you're not one conscious agent i'm
speaking to
quite a few uh probably a countless
collection of countries uncountable well
i don't know if it's uncountable but
i certainly couldn't count them but as
you know uncountable as a technical term
in mathematics so i just want to make
sure people
who know that i'm not saying it is
uncountable in that sense it may be but
i'm not claiming that um
but it's it's certainly not countable by
me so the idea is that you'll
for example we know that
there are at least two different
subjects
in in me we can see that if i take a
knife and cut the corpus callosum
which which um i have a left hemisphere
in the right hemisphere
you do too there's a band of fibers
called the core hopefully i do
yeah and sometimes i wonder
where's there 225 million fibers and if
you cut those fibers it turns out you
can actually
get clear evidence in a few people that
this has been done with
that there's a different personality in
the left hemisphere than the right
hemisphere
one in one case the left hemisphere
believed in god the right hemisphere was
an atheist
the left hemisphere wanted to be have a
desk job the right hemisphere wanted to
be a race car driver
and they can even fight the the left
hemisphere controls the right hand
the right hemisphere controls the left
hand and the they can fight the left
hand can be
fighting what the right hand is doing
you know trying to cook
the the left hand might destroy an
omelet that you're making
you try to put on some clothes the left
hand might be taking off the clothes the
right hand is trying to put on
so these two different consciousnesses
and i'm saying the
tip of an iceberg there's this whole
lattice of conscious agents that
that together um cooperate
to create um the the conscious age
that's me but but the self that i have
the the sense of of myself with my
personal history and so forth
is a data structure that i create okay i
you know i i feel like i'm slipping up
because i don't know
and this is another one by the way
causality is elusive identity
is also one of those where the closer
you look the more
liquid liquid it gets are you using
self and identity synonymously
well so no
so i'm thinking about self in the
colloquial sense that we most of you
know think about
you know i am so and so here's my name
this is my personal history
this is what's important to me this is
my goals and so
that kind of um
self that we that we that we experience
ourselves the thing that we're afraid of
losing in death and so forth right that
that
that's that is a data structure
now again that's interesting
you're saying that the self is also a
data structure yes
that's right okay sorry continue at
least in this theory
that i'm working on um and i can explain
why we're going that direction if you
want but but but the notion of a self
right so there's certain views of the
self that it's
um there's no such thing as a persisting
self
but this like this is called the pearl
view it's like the number of pearls on
a string so there's a pearl a different
instantiation of the self
at each moment along this string so
there are certain
eastern mystical traditions but also
certain western philosophers
who take this this point of view that
this there's not you don't have one
persisting self
but you have a sequence of cells and so
william james point of view um but
but the the pearl analogy would imply
that there's a continuum there's a
string
there's a string and and for james james
said the thought itself
is the thinker um which is interesting i
don't know exactly what james means by
that but he was saying that there's no
there's no thinker no self
beyond the occurring thought right now
but the but the thought itself is
creating the illusion
of a persisting thinker of a persisting
self
now many western religions on the other
hand will take
just the opposite point of view they'll
say there's a
there is of course a self and it's
eternal and what you do here
determines whether that self will go to
heaven or to hell or something like that
so so so you can see there's a lot
riding on this notion of self and there
are widely differing
points of view and the reason in
in my theory that i've been working by
the way by my throat of course i'm
not alone i've got a bunch of wonderful
collaborators
chaitan prakash bruce bennett when
you've seen chris fields
robert prentner federico fajin a bunch
of really
brilliant people so when i say my theory
you know that's
in quotes and also when you say maya
that you're implying itself
myself that's right but you're
questioning at the same time yourself
itself
sorry continue it's so tricky to talk
about this but anyway
that's right but it's fun when
our everyday assumptions
that we have never questioned in many
cases or just assumed
it's i think i find it really refreshing
to have everything that i thought i knew
blown away
i mean it's really quite fun it's it's
maybe an acquired taste
like you know but but but it's an
interesting
thing to be surprised what i thought i
knew i don't know
but in the case of the self when i was
trying to come up with the theory of
consciousness
as a scientist what you try to do when
you're
creating a theory is you're trying to
put as few assumptions as possible up
front
right because every assumption you build
in is something you're not explaining is
something you're assuming
so you want to assume as little as
possible so in the theory of conscious
agents
i don't i mean of course i could have
said okay they also have a self and they
have an i and so forth but
but i decided not to do that because it
turned out if i just said
there are these entities just call them
formal structural entities called
conscious agents
they may not at all be aware of
themselves
as entities so they may not have any
self-awareness at all
they just have conscious experiences
that's all they have
they make decisions and they take
actions but those actions
all they do is affect the conscious
experience of the other entities
that's it there's no self there's
nothing like that
there's no memory by the way there's no
intelligence
nothing it's just experiences leading to
decisions at the fundamental atomic
level
that's right the very foundational level
so that that and i do this on purpose
the the goal is to make the foundations
of your theory
as sparse as possible that's different
we do a scientist as few assumptions as
possible
sure i could have thrown in myself i
could throw in the kitchen sink let me
throw in intelligence let me throw in
just well there's nothing left to
explain i've just i've just assumed it
all right
there we go that's well there's no
theory there so that
so the reason i stopped where i stopped
was very nice
theorem by writing down a set of
experiences
conscious experiences and a so-called
markovian kernel
which is a way of talking about the
probabilities of the different decisions
that you could take
the markovian kernels are provably
computationally universal
that means that with that
little foundation experiences and
decisions to act that are modeled by
markovian kernels
i am computationally universal anything
that can be simulated by any computer
quantum or otherwise i believe can be
simulated by this network of conscious
agents so
even though my foundations are
incredibly
sparse there are there are agents
which have experiences and make choices
based on those experiences that's it
networks of agents can provably compute
anything that's computable at all
period so because i know in cognitive
neuroscience for example that we have
mathematical models that are
very very good at problem solving
um intelligence
creating all sorts of structures um i
can build networks of conscious agents
that can do anything that cognitive
neuroscience can do right now
so that's why i stopped i i don't need
anything more
i can build models of the self out of
networks of conscious agents
if if so so there's no reason for me to
assume them
i should force myself to build them from
networks of conscious agents and so
that's
that's the fun part of this the network
so i've what we've got is
essentially the tinker toys of
consciousness
now we can build up any structure that
we want provably
going back to this d and a and
p model let's forget about the p because
it's just conscious agents
the decisions and the actions are
stochastic so they're markov kernels
right where's the free will there right
so
all the of course this raises a deep
question about the relationship between
mathematics
and the thing that you're modeling with
the mathematics right all right so all
i've got
are measurable structures that i say are
conscious experiences spaces of
conscious experiences
right and then i've got these markovian
kernels which i say are
modeling the choices and you can say
well
you know i just see that i see
probabilities there but i don't see any
free will
and so it's a matter of how i interpret
those probabilities
i'm one could interpret those
probabilities as
pure objective chance and i think many
of my physicalist colleagues would
would say you know if you see
probability somewhere then um
if it's not due to ignorance if
the probabilities are not due to my
ignorance then it's due to an objective
chance
in nature and but i
want to be a monist in
my theory i don't want to be a dualist i
if i'm going to say that consciousness
is fundamental
then i don't also want
to propose as a dualist that there are
other sources of novelty
outside of consciousness into the
universe
i want consciousness to be the only
source of novelty
in in this universe objective chance
i mean what do we mean when we say
objective chance
in as a physicalist right so i suppose
i'm a physicalist i believe space-time
say is fundamental and i believe that
there are things called objective chants
that are not just due to my ignorance
this is something
objective that we call objective chances
what i'm saying
is
these probabilities objective chance i'm
saying
there is a source of novelty
coming into my universe that i cannot
explain
there is where a miracle is happening so
to be very very clear objective chance
is a miracle it's you're in in the
following sense you're saying
my theory has no resources
to explain those outcomes i cannot
predict
those outcomes that's why i'm calling it
objective chance well
that that reinterpreted re-explained is
in the language of your theory you have
no resources to explain
what's happening so in terms of your
theory that's a miracle
it's unexplainable now so every theory
and this is not a put down every theory
has its miracles we just have to own
that every scientific thing
right right and you're using miracles as
a synonym for axioms
that's right it's where it's a miracle
for your theory
if your theory has to assume it can't
explain it
okay right okay now when you have
probabilities
there are two kinds of miracles that you
can
imagine if it's not just due to lack of
knowledge right so sometimes you have
probabilities just because
there's a true state of affairs but
you're you're you don't have enough
knowledge that's a different kind of
thing
but when it's a fundamental probability
you can
either ascribe it to the miracle of
objective chance
or free will they're both
equally miracles but i since i'm trying
to have a monist theory
i interpret probability not as a as
objective chance but as
free will choices and then it's you know
up to me then in the mathematics to
unpack what does that free will choice
idea amount to and it's really quite
interesting because this is a network
dynamics
each agent at each level of the net of
the
dynamics is making its own contributions
to free will choices and there
there are bottom-up influences the free
will choices of lower level agents
influence higher agents
and vice versa and the whole system
of conscious agents also itself
is an agent by the mathematics of
mathematics says
collections of agents also form an agent
and so
what you get is this really interesting
analysis and synthesis
approach where i can get a dynamical
model
of free will bottom up and top down
at the same time and that would be my
model of the free will choice of the one
single agent and so it's it's going to
be
it's again forcing me to do the work
um is forcing me to do the work of what
what ultimately do i mean by free will
by by assigning it only to local agents
and then saying what
what do you mean by free will when you
have agents interact
what is right right so a question i have
for you
let's imagine we have this graph and
it's extended and they're all conscious
agents
okay we pick one of them but and there's
free will associated
and they influence one another does that
mean from sheer will
can one drastically change the game for
the rest
um there may be cases where that can
happen but it looks like
it's every agent
makes its contribution and
it's a it's almost like a symphony right
every member of the symphony
makes their contribution to the hole
there may be a conductor
but but um
it's it's an organic hole so where would
the conductor be in this model
well that's the thing there wouldn't
there would only be
like relative conductors that the agents
above
would have sort of top-down influence
but the agents below have really strong
bottom-up
influence on the free will decisions so
it's hard for me to say at this point
that one is more important than the
other
yeah and i'm having a difficult time
when you say that one is above another
because as far as i know from just from
reading the papers and it could be
mistaken it
it's not as if one is privileged one
node is privileged over another
right so so that's right when i say
above it's it's
it's like um my two hemispheres in my
brain
right when the corpus callosum is intact
there seems to be a unified me that i
called on
right but if you cut my corpus closum
you could easily it turns out and this
is how strange it can get
they would they were able um to get
these split brain patients to have to
play 20 questions with each other with
themselves
you the right hemisphere has a word in
mind
the left hemisphere doesn't know what it
is and then the left hemisphere which
can talk
can start asking questions is it uh
animal is it vegetable is it mineral
things like that
and the right hemisphere which can't
talk but can understand language can use
say the left hand to
thumbs up for yes thumbs down for no and
so
these a split brain patient
has two separate spheres of
consciousness so separate that they can
play 20 questions and the left
hemisphere doesn't know the answer
right the left hemisphere does not know
and sometimes will fail to guess in 20
questions what's in the mind of the
right hemisphere
now you might some people argue that
there's no separate personalities no
separate consciousnesses
um good luck making that point when you
know
the left hemisphere can fail to to win a
20 questions
game with the right hemisphere even
giving its level best
and i'm saying that's just the tip of an
iceberg but it goes all the way
it goes all the way down to what i call
these one-bit agents that have just
basically two conscious experiences say
red or nothing or something like that
um and and so it's in that sense when i
talk about agents being above
and whatever agent is me that's talking
to you
seems to be a combination of my left
hemisphere and my right hemisphere
agents
if we split my corpus closum that higher
level agent
apparently would be gone and there would
be two different agents
that could now play 20 questions with it
with each other and lose lose the game
of 20 questions with each other
whereas i couldn't play 20 questions
with myself right now and lose
but if you if you told me something i
would all i would know my left minister
would know
and i would know so that's the sense in
which i talk about agents being higher
and lower
agents can combine to create new agents
are you familiar with douglas
hofsteder's work a bit
what do you think of his theory of
consciousness it sounds similar to what
you're describing in the sense of a
strange loop that
well you can do a much better job at
describing it than i can
so
there's a fundamental difference in
the approach that we're taking um
and you know hofstadter is brilliant
right he's
a world-class genius um he's
going after the notion of of
self-referential systems
and those have really interesting
properties
right if i have a sentence that of the
form
um this sentence is false
that the sentence is referring to itself
by saying this sentence
is false the sentence is is got an a
strange loop it's got a self-referential
loop in it and then you get all sorts of
weird things that happen because is that
sentence true i mean the sentence says
the sentence
is false well if it's true then it's
false
but if it's false then it's true and you
get
caught in this weird thing and so
i mean hofstadter has a lot of brilliant
ideas and i don't want to claim that i'm
doing justice to them but but
the the key is that
there's a an essential role to this
self-referential kind of structure that
that we see
in in that kind of sentence this
sentence is so is false
and that you get um in the work of kurt
gerdel when he proves his incompleteness
theorems and so forth there's this this
really clever use of mathematics to to
refer
to itself and get self-referential kinds
of loops and
and his idea is that these kinds of
self-referential loops
are somehow critical perhaps to booting
up consciousness to booting up
what we call a self and so forth
and there's a
there's a fundamental difference in
philosophy um
in the following sense
do you mean between you and hofstetter
that's right
and and my colleagues who who
and many of my colleagues are taking a
similar kind of thing that that's saying
that
that consciousness is the result some
property
of computational systems
like this ability to have self-reference
and so forth
but it could be other properties it
could be some kind of um
compute other computational properties
of of systems
this is called you know like the
computational theory of mind and so
forth
but the idea is that you start with
systems that are
that are not conscious but if they have
certain
interesting properties like
self-reference or other computational
properties
for example certain kind of integrated
information that tanoni and koch
are looking at so they have certain
kinds of computational properties like
that they call high integrated
information
then these unconscious systems
give rise to consciousness now
i that's a fundamentally different point
of view
than the one i'm taking i'm saying look
i'm not
i'm not starting with the universe
that's unconscious
i'm proposing at the foundation
the conscious experiences are
fundamental this that's where
explanation stops
this i'm not explaining how conscious
experiences arise
i'm saying that they are what what
exists
just like a physicalist who believes in
space-time and takes it as fundamental
says
i don't know where space time comes from
i'm assuming it i'm assuming that
space-time and fundamental particles
exist right every theory is going to
make
its its own assumptions so so we're all
equal footing in that
regard we all have miracles at the start
the question is what miracles do you
pick
and the reason i don't go
with a physical starting point like a
computational system that
that most of the time is going to be
unconscious but if it has the right
integrated information or has the right
kind of self-reference
then the magic of consciousness somehow
emerges the reason i don't go after that
is a couple of reasons
one
no one has been able to use that
approach
to predict exactly even how one specific
conscious experience
could arise right so how could
self-reference or integrated information
or collapse
orchestrated collapses microtubule
states and certain neurons
be or cause my experience of the taste
of vanilla
what specific patterns of activity
of the brain or computational system
must be or must cause the taste of
vanilla
and why is it that it could not be the
taste of chocolate or the smell of
garlic
there's those theories have utterly
failed
to explain even one specific conscious
experience
in other words there's not one success
for even one specific conscious
experience on the table
that is to say why does this brain state
or this computational model correspond
to this qualia
it's not another and does your theory
deal with that
so so i i choose a different miracle so
their miracle is
grant me computational systems in space
and time
i will predict qualia well they can't
predict qualia
so i've granted them what they want and
they can't give me what they promised
they can't give me even one specific
qualia
it's a failure and by the way the
these are friends they're brilliant this
is good
they're doing great work there's not
absolutely
but i but i think that they've given
themselves an impossible task
you can't start with unconscious
ingredients and boot up consciousness
can't be done
so what i'm doing is i'm saying look
they can't explain
qualia no one's been able to explain
conscious experiences
i'm going to start with quiet i'm going
to start with
conscious experiences the taste of
garlic the smell of chocolate
all of these things those are the things
i'm going to start with
those are my so those are my miracles
right i'm not
explaining them i'm assuming them now
my goal is to say grant me this model of
that
my conscious agent model then i will
show you how space
time and quantum mechanics and general
relativity and evolution by natural
selection
come out as interface representations
of the dynamics of consciousness so
instead of starting with space time
and as my my miracle and booting up
consciousness i'm going the other way
start with conscious experiences of my
miracle i will show you how to boot up
space time
now the
the winner will be whoever can explain
the most with the least assumptions
right
right now my colleagues my good friends
who are physicalists are assuming
space-time and computational systems
and they have yet failed to explain even
one conscious experience
i'm starting with conscious experiences
that no one can explain i can't explain
them either i'm assuming them
but if i can explain how space-time and
quantum mechanics and general relativity
come out then i have fewer miracles than
them so that wins
whichever theory has the fewer miracles
is the one we should prefer that's sort
of occam's razor
in your theory why is it that we would
let's say taste vanilla why is it that
we would have one experience taste of
villain
vanilla versus the sight of tico mielmo
which is another conscious experience
well i don't have an answer to that
right now
so and and the
very existence of conscious experiences
is something that i don't explain it's
something i assume
right so so my colleagues and
my physicalist colleagues would like to
say
just the opposite of what i'm saying
they would like to say we don't assume
the conscious experiences are
fundamental
in fact at the big bang there were no
conscious experiences there was just
space time and matter
and energy and so we will tell you how
conscious experiences
emerge from that but they failed to do
so
i'm saying you guys assume space time
and
matter and energy i'm going to assume
conscious experiences
what i'm asking for is i understand that
you're assuming the
various qualia but why is it that one
is chosen versus another it sounds to me
like a similar problem that the
physicalists have which is to explain
why one qualia over another
and i don't have an answer to that
that's that's that's a very very good
question
the
and and to really make that question
intense
we can look at people with synesthesia
right so
um there was a synesthesia about four
percent of the population has
synesthesia a human population has four
synesthesia and to be
100 if you take lsd i want to talk about
psychedelics by the way
sorry continue right so so there's this
one guy like
michael watson um his synesthesia was
that everything he tasted
with his tongue he felt as a
three-dimensional shape
in space that's your friend uh he wasn't
a friend of mine but he um
he was studied um extensively by a
neurologist
um he he died
he's dead now but but okay but
but he was a great cook um everything
that he tasted that's interesting that's
interesting
he felt with his hands so mint was a
tall
cold smooth column of glass he could
feel it he could feel the weight of it
he could feel the the coldness of the
surface he could feel the smoothness of
the surface with his hand
angostura bitters which is a something
you put in drinks
felt like a basket of ivy he could feel
the leaves the sponginess the texture
the warmth
so it was a very rich sensory experience
that he had
and so you and i don't have
most of us don't have those experiences
when we cook he did
and it allowed him to be an exceptional
cook he had this other way of of
dealing with complex tastes when he was
putting
you know foods together so so that
raises your question really really
sharply why is it that we experience
when we put something on our tongue why
do we experience it as
what we call taste saltiness sugar you
know sweetness and so forth
why don't we all experience it like
michael watson did as
shapes that we feel with our hands in
space
now what was what's interesting is that
there
mathematically there was probably some
kind of homomorphism
that you could write down mathematically
between the shapes
and the textures and the weights and so
forth he felt with his hands
and the experiences of taste
that we all feel so so there's probably
some homomorphism that
some mapping some dictionary between
what he felt with his hand and what we
taste uh what we experienced with her
taste
and and that's why your question is so
difficult in in many cases
from a functional point of view
the details of exactly why you have that
experience
don't matter lots of other kinds of qual
qualitative experiences could have the
same functional structure as those
experiences
so in fact you count them in one of your
papers you count the amount of
homomorphisms
that's right which which makes me wonder
like erase like why why this and not
another given that there are so many
homomorphisms so here's the best i
mentioned
okay this is the best i've got so far on
this right
so you so first of all i just wanted to
say hats off you asked a really
good good question it's a really tough
question and this
synesthesia thing really makes it clear
how
why your question is so tough right
the only idea i've got right now
that i think is interesting enough
is based on girdle's incompleteness
theorem great
familiar with this girl so yeah yeah i'm
gonna ask you about that later yeah
right so girdles incompleteness theorem
um
in intuitively basically says that
there's no end
to the exploration of mathematical
structure
and
if we take consciousness as fundamental
as as i'm proposing then there's only
one thing that mathematical structure
could be about
which is consciousness conscious
experiences
and so in that context girdles
incompleteness theorem would i would
interpret as saying that there's an
infinite variety
of kinds of conscious experience that
are out there of possible structures of
conscious experience
and for each kind of structure that
there is there's an infinite variety of
conscious experiences that all share
that structure
right so i would so i would call this
girls candy store
this infinite variety of possible
structures of conscious experiences
and with each with for each structure
probably an infinite variety of
conscious experiences that that share
that structure so this very very rich
and the goal of consciousness then on
this theory would be
to explore girdle's candy store that's
what consciousness is up to
girdle basically his incompleteness
theorem is saying
no matter how much mathematics you have
you haven't even begun
no matter how much structure you've
explored you've not even begun
because there's endless endless
exploration in some sense
god could never know it all there would
be and so god has endless
whatever you think about god there's an
endless structure
for even god to explore right and so
that
endless exploration of all the rich
varieties and
it's it's here i don't know here i don't
know how to think about it yet
is it an exploration
of a pre-existing candy store or is it
an
invention of all the new candies in this
endless store
my my feeling right now is it's an
invention
that girdle is telling us girdles
incompleteness theorem is saying
there's an infinite variety of
structures to be invented
and then in the context of consciousness
i interpret it as saying
an infinite variety of conscious
experiences to be
invented i think it's invented not
explored you know in terms of
pre-existing conscious experiences
but there i must say my my intuitions at
this point fail me i don't know
okay let's go even further off the deep
end sure you're
completely allowed to speculate i'm not
michael schumer i'm not gonna
throw skepticism at you skepticism to
you straight out the gate
what where in your model does
god lie well
it's the the word god
is something that's been used in various
forms for thousands of years by human
beings
and it's never been precisely defined
right
never been precisely defined there's
there's quite a few of those words
causality free will identity
god slippery slippery but they all might
be related
but we don't kill each other over our
differences about the word causality
we do kill each other over our
differences about the word god
and we then so that's a particularly
troublesome
problem that we have that that we think
that's a very very important word
and in many cases in human history we've
proven that we're willing to kill
millions of people
who disagree with us about what we mean
by that word
and the remarkable thing is that's when
there's no precise definition
so i would like to propose a precise
definition of god
all right let's hear it and of course
i'm wrong
of course i'm wrong but the idea is to
have something on the table so that we
can now
begin to figure out why it's wrong so i
have this definition of a conscious
agent
i'll just propose that a con that god is
any conscious agent that has an infinite
set of
of possible conscious experiences
start there now of course i'm wrong but
now the fun part is
where what's wrong with it now oh wait
that to me sounds like there could be
multiple guns
because you could have multiple agents
that's for infinite sets
that's exactly right one so now
by the way with that definition it may
end up being a theorem
that polytheism is true not monotheism
but so what but notice
all of a sudden that we we get this
thing where
we're now i gave you a definition of god
and you immediately saw an implication
try that with with most other religious
views of god that they're not precise
enough
to to have these kinds of inferential
implications where we can actually what
if someone said
okay i can save monotheism by saying
that god is the amalgam of all the
conscious agents
and that would be that would be another
way to to go at it
and you might not and that might be the
critique that you give of my first
definition of god it would be my
critique of my first definition of god
would be to say well no let god
be the top conscious agent the the the
one that's the unit
um you know the super saiyan nation the
combination of all the other agents that
exist
but then we may turn out as we look at
the dynamics of conscious agents and the
combination
we may find that there is no at any
moment there may not be a single
maximum so it may not be a lattice where
there's one peak
to the whole network there may be
multiple and and no single
maximal at any one at any one moment in
the dynamics so so again
it would be a matter of and it may turn
out to be a
property of the kind of dynamics of
conscious agents that you propose
that in these kinds of dynamics it's a
polytheism and this one there's a
monotheism
so so that's what's so fun about this is
now all of a sudden we're
we're already engaging by the way like
this on on
the word god in a way that we could
never before engaged
this is now a technical term now and
again of course
everything that we've said so far is
almost surely deeply wrong
but it's precise and so we can find out
precisely where it's wrong
and and by the way notice now we're in a
very different space
i'm not tempted to kill you or or hurt
you because you disagree with me
i'm rather tempted to listen to your
ideas and go oh wow that's really cool
i hadn't thought about that let me let
me rethink my position
it's a very very different kind of thing
and so can we
i mean it seems that the word god is
very very important to us
instead of having it be an ambiguous
term that we
fight to the death over and hate each
other over
why not have it be
since we think it's so important
it's important enough to be precise
if it's that important to us then it's
important enough that we should be
precise about what we mean
and if we're precise about what we mean
then we can start to have a dialogue and
try to refine it
and and come to some kind of mutual
understanding
so so that's sort of the scientific
attitude of
um be precise so that we
don't get stuck in the same thoughts
that we've had for thousands of years we
don't
end up being dogmatic defenders of
something that's not even well defined
rather we it's it's a sense of humility
these are the best ideas that i and my
tradition
have had so far about god there's
probably
a lot of insight in those ideas and
there's probably some mistakes
let me listen to your ideas
let's have you listen to my ideas
and can we then get to a new and deeper
and more precise notion of god
since we agree that this seems to be an
important concept for us
can we together work in humility
and both admit up front that maybe we
don't have it quite right
that's sort of the scientific attitude
about this thing being pre
being precise is an ultimate act
of humility on the one hand because
you're making yourself vulnerable to
being shown wrong
but it's also the ultimate act of true
inquisitiveness
it's saying this is precisely the best
idea i've got so far
but i really want to understand so i'm
stating it precisely
so i can figure out where i'm wrong and
then we can move on
into a deeper inquiry so that's what i
would like to see in the in the
discussion
of god i would love to see in this sense
a
scientific spirituality which doesn't
mean a dry desiccated
you know academic kind of discipline
it's rather taking
these very important notions and giving
them the respect that they deserve
a precise definition
and a precise inquiry into what we mean
that could eventually then lead to a
deeper understanding of right and wrong
of morals
what is a good life what is the meaning
of life and so forth
but if we can't even define our basic
terms how will we ever
make progress on the deeper questions
okay we're in the defend already let's
go to the
mariana trench what happens when you
die well
if you're a physicalist
it's quite clear right your
consciousness
is entirely the product
of your brain or your embodied
brain i mean some of my colleagues will
will emphasize
the cycle between sort of an inactive
point of view that
it's not just the brain it's the brain
and the body in the environment in that
loop
that loop fine but
when you die that loop stops and
therefore your consciousness stops and
so from that point of view it's it's
the prediction is quite clear there's
nothing that survives death
um from you that that i'm proposing here
space time itself is not fundamental
the brain does not cause anything
including our conscious experiences
instead
instead space time is like our headset
it's a virtual reality headset
but so consciousness
does not have to die
when the body dies but as i said
the self is not fundamental in the
theory that i'm developing
the self is just a data structure like
space time is a data structure
so from the point of view that i'm
working on right now
my death does not mean that
my consciousness disappears but myself
may
i don't know yet i mean that's going to
be something i want to work on in
this theory the self just being a data
structure maybe that data structure
dissolves
um or maybe it's like
[Music]
what happens in metamorphosis
a caterpillar becoming a butterfly
right in some sense there's not much
recognizable
left of the caterpillar when the
butterfly emerges
um there is a a continuity
but you know the butterfly has
only six legs the the caterpillar
had quite a few more the caterpillar
eats leaves
the butterfly can't eat leaves the
butterfly drinks nectar the caterpillar
never drank nectar
the butterfly has wings caterpillar has
no concept of wings
they're they're the same creature at
different stages but they're utterly
alien and and maybe the thing that
survives
death is as different from me as a
butterfly is from a caterpillar
um and it you know so i i just don't
know so
um i'm still on that i'll be
be very interested to work on the
mathematics and see
um but i'll give you an analogy
that maybe that may be helpful here so
suppose you go to a virtual reality
arcade with some friends
to place a virtual volleyball you put on
your headset and bodysuit
and you see yourself emerge immersed in
a
beach volleyball scene you see palm
trees and the net and sand and
your friend the avatars of your friends
cross the net
and so you serve the virtual volleyball
and you guys play for a while
and then one of your friends you know
bob says excuse me i'm thirsty i'm gonna
go get a drink
and he takes off his headset in his body
suit to go get a drink
and his avatar collapses on the sand
well within that virtual reality
he's effectively dead but
of course bob isn't dead he just stepped
out of the interface
and so there's the sense in the theory
that i'm developing
that your body is just an avatar
the death of your body just like the
death of bob
in the virtual reality game is not the
death of bob bob just was not getting a
drink
so death may just be stepping out of the
interface but even if consciousness
survives
the consciousness that survives maybe is
different from the consciousness that
you now have as
you could imagine a butterfly being
different from a caterpillar
even more in the analogy of bob going to
get a drink there's a retainment of
memory
in your model i recall you
saying earlier in the conversation that
you don't have a
a theory for memory or there is no
memory i could be wrong you might but
regardless does memory survive death
is it possible memories are data
structures as well
so those data structures
may may or may not be preserved so that
would be another aspect of this whole
thing but
right now i have no reason to say up
front
that i would claim that they necessarily
are preserved so
i can't claim that that your current
notion of self would be preserved
or your current memories would be
preserved and
the issue would then be could i build
models
of conscious agents in which
i first modeled what the death process
is as
in terms of stepping out of a particular
interface and can i find models
so but but notice what i'm saying here
now i'm actually trying to model the
death process
with a mathematical model in terms of
conscious agents and then i'm asking a
technical question
could certain data structures self data
structure
memory my own personal episodic memory
data structures
be retained
in this other process that that is
leading to the extraction of
a conscious agent out of a particular
interface
that i don't know the answer to it but
for me it's a technical question and a
really interesting one
and and one that i don't think is beyond
our scope i think it's one that we can
address we can try to find what i like
about
what i like about your approach is it
reminds me of newtonian approximation
where you just guess at what one of the
roots are and you're
knowing you know full well that it's
likely to be wrong
but because of that guess you can get
closer and closer to the truth
that's how science works right you you
you guess at the foundations
you guess of what the right assumptions
are newton did a brilliant job i mean
he's probably one of the smartest men
that ever lived maybe the smartest
uh incredible brilliance and and
where he was wrong he
the new theories give i give newton as
an approximation
like well einstein gives newton as a
limiting case as the speed of light goes
to infinity
right newton um is wrong but but he's
deeply right too he had his hands on
something
so we would like to have assumptions in
this area of consciousness
as minimal as possible
but that then lead that turn all the
kinds of questions you're asking
into technical problems that we can in
principle solve and
all the questions you're asking so far
are ones i think that we can
pose as technical questions and try to
solve them
let's get back to girdles and
completeness theorem people like penrose
and lucas would say that
any system that's computational in
nature which yours sounds like
or at least it's algorithmic or
rule-based
would necessarily fail at a model of
consciousness because
within that system there are truths that
that system cannot see
as being true but we can
how does your how do you deal with that
what do you think of that
well so
there are non-computable functions
right and this is something that penrose
knows quite well
and is focused on in some of his work so
in fact it's quite remarkable if you
just look
at the integers or even just the natural
numbers let's say the integers no
and you ask look at all the functions
from the integers to the integers
right well it's
mathematicians can show that there's an
uncountable set of functions
from the integers to the integers
because the number of functions is the
power set of the integer so it's it's
higher cardinality than the energies so
it's an
uncountable scent but
turing proved that the set
of all computable functions
is countable
therefore when we look at just
the collection of functions from the
integers to the integers
which is uncountable what that means is
that
almost no function is computable
when you look at the set of all
functions the set of computable
functions
is probability zero for some interesting
measure
so so the reason we
focus on computable functions is partly
because of our lack of imagination it's
hard for us to imagine
uncomputable functions right if you've
taken a class in computer science where
you actually have to like
deal with uncomputable functions um
you can get there you can study in a
non-computable function
but boy is it hard it really strips all
the gears in your head
it's just so hard for us but so most
functions are not computable
our brains have a hard time even
understanding one of them
so it's a real limitation of our brains
so
in my field cognitive neuroscience we're
giving computational theories of mind
there is a way to look at this to
what my my field is doing um and say
what are you guys up to
you're you're trying to give
computational theories of
cognition if you're if you're saying
that cognition is only based on
computation
you're claiming that of all the
functions that are available there's
this probability zero subset of
functions that that are only responsible
for our minds and for consciousness
right you know if like you know the
tinonian
coke approach of you know integrated
information
it's a computational function so why
should we assume that cognition in
general in consciousness
um is restricted to this probability
zero subset of functions
what what's what's the principled reason
for that
and most of my colleagues don't even
understand that this is an issue and
certainly don't have an answer for it
but but of course
penrose is an exception penrose is
saying he unders he understands all this
but but i still don't agree with what
where penrose goes on this right
penrose is is saying
he still wants to start with a
physicalist framework
and get consciousness to emerge by some
kind of
um objective reduction of forget about
that
i i'd say it's more fundamental the
w the conscious agent model looks to me
to be algorithmic or rule-based
and the statement from penrose
independent of whether or not
consciousness emerges from physicality
just forget about that
is that a rule-based system can't
account for
our conscious behavior given that we
have an understanding of what's
true but not provable within that
rule-based
system any rule-based system and because
we have that quality
our consciousness can't be relegated to
an algorithm which yours seems like now
it could just be this is rudimentary
form kurt i'm like i'm a step one
or there might be another counter and
i'm just curious to know what you think
well so again the framework of what i'm
doing is different from what
what what he's trying to do right i i'm
not too
i'm not trying to explain how
consciousness arises
i'm assuming it so consciousness is
given
now there's a question do
consciousnesses interact only by rule
right now i'm studying rules
and but but i'm completely open to
non-computational
modes of interaction among these
countries has no
bearing because see i'm not trying to
say how consciousness arises
i'm saying it it's it exists it's
fundamental
but the kinds of interactions the
consciousnesses have
surely if they're i don't want to
exclude
rule-based interactions but i may find
that i don't want to restrict to
rule-based interaction
so i'm starting with the rule-based ones
partly because of my background and my
limitations
but eventually i'd love to to go beyond
so i so i would say point well taken
non-computational approaches may be very
very interesting um
in this absolutely there's a cockpit of
scientist named jonathan
verveiki or john verveicky and he says
that there are four
i i don't know if they're all orthogonal
they're definitely related but there's
four different modes of
knowledge and one is propositional and
that's what since the science since the
development of the scientific method
we've relegated our knowledge to
the propositions are what are true but
he says well there are others there's
participatory knowing
there's procedural knowledge obviously
like that one anyone can get
and then there's perspective and i'm
curious
it's like how would one even if your
if your theory would incorporate then
how the heck can you even write down
because this
notion of writing down is a proposition
how would one model the other three
fundamentally well so
in current neural network models
um the way that the network learns
is not by acquiring new propositions is
by updating
connection weights in the network that's
a procedural knowledge
what what the so the
the history of ai i i was in the
artificial intelligence lab at mit
um that's did my phd there and in the
brain and cognitive science department
at mit from 79 to 83.
at the time ai was mostly about
propositional right it was good
old-fashioned ai so we were
it was explicit algorithms with specific
things that you could write down as
propositions and so forth um
but with neural networks you have this
kind of thing where
um the system learns but it's not
learning propositions
you're just updating weights and you're
getting behaviors
and that turns out to be very very
effective for modeling
procedural memories like like motor
memories and so forth and in fact
at boston dynamics i believe um
they've made great progress by by doing
that by having
robots that fall down and try things and
they they
they walk fall down but their neural
networks are just updating and updating
and updating
and they they don't get any list of
propositions do this you know do this
actuator then do that actuator
no it's just this procedural memory
um so so we have
so there's been this big debate between
propositional procedural that's gone on
between
the neural network modelers and the good
old-fashioned ai kinds of modelers and
and so forth and you know it's a
profitable debate
and and then there's the inactive
or embody cognition kind of thing that
comes into it as well
i'm taking a perspectival thing as well
right so i'm saying that that in some
sense conscious experiences and
perspectives therefore
are are fundamental but i i see
within the network of conscious agents
being able to get both procedural
and explicit propositional kinds of
representations coming out but i think
also as you said
i should be looking at non-computational
approaches to this
and um i've got some mathematician
friends
working with me who are expert in
category theory
um so category theory is a great way to
to explode this into a very very general
mathematical framework and we intend to
go there
i know you got to go soon i'm going to
just get to the
the best of questions are the ones that
i like answered which might be more
technical
okay at some point you use landauer's
limit
i you know what i'm you recall what i'm
referring to okay
why do you use that when landorus limit
presupposes space and time why do you
use that as a limit for the amount of
ticks
or the energy that goes into a tick um
we've
used that and this is um largely the uh
the brilliance of my friend chris fields
who's who's a
physicist who's been working on that so
he likes to look at the
information theoretic things using
landauer's principle and to look
so most of his analyses are in terms of
quantum theory
and what what are the limits of
information transfer in quantum systems
so that's usually the context in which
we bring that up
um ultimately if we
get a theory of space time trying to
emerge from our theory of conscious
agents
then once again we will face landauer's
kind of limit when we look at
how our space-time model
um is capturing features of the
information dynamics of conscious agents
so
it will come there as a property of the
interface but not as a fundamental limit
of of consciousness okay okay and
does that give a bound for the amount of
time
for each click so just so people are
aware there was that model that i'll
show on the screen there's the wxg
i was simplifying it there's a t that's
in the middle that counts
the amount of revolutions in the system
i could be wrong just correct me
but either way that to me seems akin to
time
and then in the paper it seemed like you
were giving a lower limit to time saying
that
the amount that a conscious agent can
experience is something like 100
femtoseconds
please correct me if i'm incorrect here
and i thought that
well that sounds like a theoretical
prediction too that if we can get a
camera or
conscious experience of a quicker time
then that would invalidate it or if we
can't then that would be evidence for it
right so so i i don't go that direction
with it
um and i don't think that chris fields
goes that direction with it
either and for the following reason um
there there is no
fundamental pixelation of space-time
right so space-time is doomed
not because we run into pixels at the
planck scale
but rather because space time itself
ceases to be well defined
it's not a it's not an empirically
observable construct
at that level the attempts
to think about space time as being
pixelated
at roughly the blank scale run into a
very serious problem
um they're not lorenz invariant the
pixels
what's tiny for you may not be tiny for
someone else so
it's been no one has a way to make the
pixelation of space-time lorenz
invariant
and and so i wouldn't want to go there
and i don't think
chris fields would would want to go
there nevertheless we may find
i mean the the landauer limit does play
a role in information transfers
in space time so we will want to
understand where that limit comes from
from our theory of consciousness
and our theory of emergent space time
but i don't see us getting any
predictions about a pixelation of time
or pixelation of space because it would
violate
lorenz and variance okay
on the interface theory when i'm not
looking at let's say the moon
it's it doesn't necessarily exist but
you're saying that the
what doesn't exist is our idea of the
moon or that the
that our idea is representing something
that something still persists it's just
our idea of the moon doesn't exist
right so when i say the moon doesn't
exist um
i'm i'm saying it in the same way that
if i look
like at a an image and see an illusory
cube
and i say and then someone and then and
sometimes the cube i see one corner
one face in front and sometimes it flips
and i see another face in front
um and then when i look away i say that
there is no such thing as the cube
because the cube only exists when i look
at it and then i see the cube and it's
flipping
the same thing with the moon the moon is
like that cube
now there is some reality that i'm
interacting with
and it continues to exist whether or not
i look but that that reality
is not inside space and time at all much
less is at the moon
space and time themselves are not a
fundamental reality
they are data structures that we create
so anything that's in space time
is in some sense no more real than the
illusory cube that i look
and then destroy when i look away
spacetime itself is created and
destroyed by us
also only exists in the same way that
that illusory cube exists
which isn't to say that there isn't
something that exists but it's not even
in space and time whenever it exists
it's outside of space and time
um it's outside of my headset
spacetime see i see so let's imagine
there's tickle me elmo
and there's a cat and i see that tickle
me elmo but you're like okay you don't
you look it's gone it's destroyed it's
not rendered anymore but a camera that i
just pressed record on
can record the tickle memo then i can go
and press play
how do you account for that well notice
you only see the elmo on the camera when
you look you only see the camera when
you look
so the camera itself is again um just
something that exists when you
when you perceive it it's pointing to
another reality there is a reality that
exists
independent of you but the reality is
not the camera and it's not the digital
recording on the camera those are just
again your own icons
so the camera itself is just a simple
and how does the
how does your theory i know you've
covered this before but um just for the
people
who are listening how does your theory
account for inter-subject subjective
agreement
inter-subjective agreement ah now that
is one of our current projects
right so one of the one of the papers
we're working on right now
is exactly that problem because the
is critical to science right the way
scientists
typically talk about it about what
science is doing is
is that what makes science special in
some sense is that one scientist can
look at a physical system like
this
animal or this planet and another
scientist
can make their own independent
measurements of that animal that
specific animal or that planet
and then we can go and compare notes in
other words we have this notion of
public physical objects objects that are
really there
whether or not we exist like dinosaur
bones right
the dinosaur bones have been there for
200 million years
they were there if no one had ever been
around they would still be there i can
look at the dinosaur bones you can look
at the dinosaur bones they're public
physical objects we can make our
measurements
get the dna and so forth that's gone
in my point of view that whole point of
view is gone because
space time itself is doomed space time
isn't fundamental there are no public
physical objects
so how do we rethink what we mean by
objectivity
in science where objectivity has to do
with again
having independent scientists do their
own experiments and come to some
agreement
so the framework that i'm working on
right now
poses that as a really serious question
and so we're writing a paper on that
right now we're going to be running
simulations but but
here's the kind of idea that i'm playing
with
i think that we have to take the
possibility of synesthesia
very seriously we actually know
synesthesia occurs
it could be easily in the cards that
your
visual experiences that you described
with the words
red and round and square and so forth
and i described
if i could get inside your head for all
i know
i would go whoa whoa that's not what i
would call
red and round that's what i would call
the smell of garlic and the taste of
butter um or a headache those are
the just like michael watson
he he tastes mint but he feels a tall
cold smooth column of glass i don't feel
that if all michael watson ever
experienced were the feelings in his
hand
he would have a perfectly good taste
sensation he could cook
he could figure out what what foods are
so in other words we could you and i as
scientists
could absolutely agree
believe that we're talking the same
language and yet your
experiences could be synesthetically
utterly different from mine
and we would never know and i think that
that's
going to turn out to be a fundamental
and unbreachable limit
to what we can know and to
the degree of objectivity that we can
have in science
we the technical thing would be that we
can only agree
up to effectively a homomorphism
a homomorphism of your set of perceptual
representations and experiences
and mine the homomorphism could be as
radical as the difference between
the taste of mint and the tall cold
smooth column of glass it could be
that different and we would never know
the only reason we know in michael
watson's case is because he had both and
he could tell us about both
we could say oh well i understand the
one but gee i never thought about the
other
that's that's incredible um so
so we're gonna have to understand what
is the most
confirmation and what's the greatest
level of agreement
that scientists can have given this
possibility of
synesthetic complete divergence
between us
and i would love to i was talking with
my colleagues on this
in the paper that we're writing we may
actually do this
not just as a thought experiment paper
we may actually do this i would love to
create this really interesting virtual
reality game
two-player game or multiplayer but for
one player
it's it it they're immersed in what
seems like say grand theft auto
player is immersed in a completely
different game like super mario brothers
but i've arranged it so they both think
that they're playing the same game
and they are actually playing and they
win and lose
and but they have no idea that the other
person is in a completely different
virtual world
and they but they're also they're
they're using language they seem to
agree
right you take them out of their heads
and have them swap and
blow their minds when they find out what
the other person was doing i think we
can do that
and so we have to be if that's true if
that's possible
in category theory that would be the
idea that you might have
this one category for your
representation
the other scientists might have another
category but if there's some functor
if there's some functor that maps the
objects and relations
that you have in your interface to the
objects and relations that the other
scientist has in their interface if you
have the right functor
then the scientists will have the
appearance of agreement and they will
never know that they're
separated by this functor
and so i think that there's going to be
category theoretic analyses ahead
on this that are going to be really
quite stunning but i think that's going
to be the future of the philosophy of
science
is this category theoretic fundamental
limitation on the
agreement that scientists can have there
are no public physical objects
so what does it mean for us to get
laboratory independent verification my
laboratory gets it
your laboratory gets it what are we
really doing in that case it's going to
be up to some functor
right it sounds to me i only have three
three more questions
and they might be long but i have three
questions it sounds to me like you're
saying
that there are some homomorphic
functions between us
and that's responsible for why we feel
like we share a similar world
however can we not use the same argument
that you use
to show that the probability that we see
the truth is zero that is that the
immiscible functions
grow much larger than the homomorphic
functions to the structure
can we not use that to say that the
probability that we share
any interface is also zero including
homomorphic
right aspects um not not at least
within the theory of conscious agents in
the dynamics that i'm
talking about now because what we can do
is we can ask are there certain
strategies of interaction that conscious
agents can have
where they would converge in the limit
to homomorphic things
right so that's different evolutionary
game theory where the rules have been
spelled out i mean i i
in that i don't get to play with it
because they're constraints so it's not
just uniform probability
that that's right so i see i see so in
the case of conscious agents
the question is can we find dynamics
in which the agents can converge up to
homomorphisms and i think we can
okay here's one that's super
philosophical if what you're saying is
that
we are not tuned for truth because truth
is deleterious at least compared to
fitness which is
so lubrious however let's imagine your
theory is correct
then we're starting to see the truth
does that not mean that
it's deleterious we shouldn't do that
we're not designed for that
um absolutely not and so here's where
it's very very careful to
to again see the game that i'm playing
the game that i'm playing is
i take evolution at us on its own terms
and i see what its implications are i
don't i don't say i believe evolution
i'm just playing the game
this is what the math of evolution says
it says very clearly we don't see the
truth
okay that's what evolution says
probability of zero that we see the
truth that's not what hoffman says
hoffman doesn't care about that except
to understand that that's what evolution
says
but evolution says that doesn't mean i
believe it so i'm free
on the one hand to prove that evolution
entails we don't see the truth
i'm free to prove that and then to step
back and say i still believe we see the
truth here's my theory in which we see
the truth
but the constraint will then be okay
then
you if you have this theory in which we
see the truth you have to explain how it
is
in that framework where you see the
truth that you
end up arriving at the theory of
evolution of natural selection which
says otherwise
if you can't do that then you're wrong
so so so this is
a really and by the way it's a great
question because i get this question in
emails quite quite
a bit um so so the the key thing is this
hofmann doesn't say we don't see the
truth evolution by natural selection
says we don't see the truth
i don't say that evolution of natural
selection says that i just
i'm just the messenger right that's what
evolution is
don't shoot me i'm just the messenger um
i'm just pointing out what
one of our best theories entails now i'm
stepping back and i'm going
i i would like to see the truth of
course maybe i can't
i'm not saying i know that we can see
the truth i'm just saying
as a scientist i would like to come up
with a theory
which entails that we see the truth and
that's why i'm looking at consciousness
because
i am conscious so if i'm conscious and
the reality is consciousness
there is some connection between me and
the reality i might actually be able to
understand that reality because
i'm conscious but then the burden is on
me
to then explain how my theory where i
see the truth of these conscious agents
leads to an interface of space time
and in that interface this theory of
evolution natural selection
which says you don't see the truth well
that won't be so strikingly strange
because
evolution is telling you that what you
see in the interface isn't the truth
well i'm also saying that from this
bigger picture i'm saying that there's
this
this realm of conscious agents outside
the space time interface that's the
truth
and you can't see it within the
interface well it's not going to be a
surprise that evolution by natural
selection says that
inside the interface so it'll all work
out so
so so that's i hope that gives that's a
great question okay
let me quick let me rephrase it so that
i get it across
because i don't think i portrayed it
correctly
you're saying that and i'm sorry
evolutionary theory is saying that we're
not designed for
the truth we're designed for fitness
right and those are two completely
separate phenomena okay
the cl if we were designed for truth if
we were able to see the truth
that would be horrible for us but at the
same time
you're like i want to look at the truth
so i'm gonna
let's say you're actually uncovering the
truth is that not
harmful given the presupposition that
we should be pursuing fitness and not
truth
no it's not because by stepping outside
of the entire framework of evolution i'm
stepping outside of its assumptions
i'm saying there's a deeper framework in
which the assumptions of evolution
aren't true
i see i see only true within the headset
the headset is just a headset there's
this deeper reality outside the headset
it's it's like if i see the twitterverse
only through my headset
and there's certain rules about how i
perceive in the headset and i assume
that those rules of what i see in the
headset
must apply to all the twitter users well
that's stupid the twitter users are
doing their own thing
my headset is is just smashing all this
complexity
into this trivial little headset and
that's why evolution has to tell us
that it's not seeing the truth because
what's happened from this bigger
framework is
space time and and objects in spacetime
is this incredible smashing down
information losing map from the reality
this vast social network into
this trivial little space-time
interface so it's no surprise that
evolution by natural selection is saying
you know what
you're not going to see the truth you're
just going to see little interface
symbols
that's what it's telling us and i say i
agree we're only seeing interface
symbols but
that's only in space time we're not
stuck in space time you and i are not in
space time
we create space time the rules of the
game apply within the game but you can
step out of the game
that's right okay okay the authors of
the game
okay cool cool i'm gonna
i'm gonna instead of asking you i'm
gonna
list the last questions and then you
just choose one because i know you've
got to go
yeah okay so i was going to say where
does p where do people like deepak
chopra take your message too far
so that's an option you can answer that
another one is when jesus says i am the
way the truth and the light
what truth do you think he was referring
to and then the other question
what determines the initial world state
well those are all all tough um with
with deepak
deepak and i have been good friends for
for several years now
um it's he's
a spiritual teacher i'm not
uh we respect each
i other respect him as as a seeker
and he's he's he's learning to be
careful about how he
throws around words like quantum
mechanics and so forth i mean he's been
he's been i'm aware he's taken hits in
the past and i think that
that but i have really he and i
and this is really important science and
spirituality
do need to have a dialogue and whenever
there's a dialogue
even within members of two different
scientific disciplines
you have to have a lot of patience with
the other person so you know
someone who is not a cognitive scientist
coming to talk to me say he's a chemist
well when i start talking chemistry with
him i'm going to feel like and
be really stupid compared to him when he
talks cognitive science to me it's
he's going to be really pedestrian to me
it's going to be the same thing in
science and spirituality
so if i want productive dialogue of
course
i'm going to be saying things that to
someone who's spiritually
trained is going to sound you know
scientific
nonsense and immature and not very deep
and vice versa
so so of of course i'll have said things
that that
deepak thinks are spiritually stupid
and then he says things that you know on
quantum mechanics and so forth that that
you know most scientists would say
that's not what a
you know a really trained scientist
would say
fine but if we want to have a dialogue
that's
really productive we have to
cut each other some slack we have to
listen past the barriers and understand
you know it took me many many years to
understand what i know about cognitive
science
i can't expect someone to just pop into
my field and sound like they know what
they're talking about
if i'm not willing to cut them some
slack we'll never get a dialogue so for
me
that that's so i i and i learned from my
dialogue with deepak he he learns
in his dialogue with me and we've
learned to have this respect
of what each other knows and trying to
learn from the other so
so that's what i hope um we we mirror
um and of course it's my job to
gently correct him when i see things
that he says that might be wrong and
it's his job to gently correct me when i
misstate his tradition for example
so that's that's perfectly fine on jesus
i don't know what to say about
um i mean i was raised uh
my father was a fundamentalist christian
minister and so i
i've read the bible cover to cover more
than once
i know what the standard interpretation
of the bible is
among protestant fundamentals christians
what jesus meant when he said i am the
way the truth and life
um i don't know i i'll just say
i don't know
i i will say that
i think that there are many beautiful
insights in the bible
and and i think there's also nonsense
and i think that
just like in scientific theories there
are many beautiful insights
and then there are places where we know
we're absolutely wrong and and my
attitude
in for any scripture and for any
scientific theory is the same
let's treasure the insights
and let's recognize humbly
that we can be wrong any religious
tradition
any scripture any scientific theory if
we're not willing
to be wrong
to open up to the possibility that
something we deeply believe could be
deeply wrong
we can't grow that's the place where we
stop growing
so it's it's a matter of humility
both to listen to to other traditions
other points of view to be open that
they may have insights i've never had
i may have insights that they've never
had i may have nonsense
that they can point out they may have
nonsense that i can point out
if we can do it in this respectful way
again like the kind of thing i'm trying
to do with with depop
i i don't want to have them say
something wrong about quantum mechanics
and go
ugh you said that about quantum
mechanics forget it i'm not going to
talk to you anymore you got that wrong
that's that's not the way to do it
that's it it's it's to have
a respectful dialogue if others are
willing to
humbly also put out their ideas and
listen
that i think is the heart of true
religion when we talk about loving each
other
what deeper love can you have than to
respectfully
and carefully listen to the thoughts and
opinions of others
and be willing to entertain the
possibility
that they may be right in some places
and you may be wrong
that's a deep respectful and humble kind
of interaction
and that's how we will learn and that's
how we'll stop killing each other too
thank you don where can the audience
find out more about you
um i if you google
donald hoffman hof fman my um home page
at university california comes up and
i've got links to my papers and
i have a book um the case against
reality
published by norton so the case against
reality is a great place to get
these ideas for a broad audience it's
not a technical book